schönen guten tag zdf heute live here
deutschland steht vor weitreichenden
lockerungen in der korona pandemie mal
wieder muss man sagen seit etwa halb
drei bespricht bundeskanzler scholz
zusammen mit den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten der länder wie
weit man öffnen will wir werden die
pressekonferenz hier live zeigen sie
sehen das bild noch passiert da nichts
im kanzleramt und wir sind dabei wenn es
losgeht wann es los geht das weiß man
nie so genau es ist gerade die rede von
20 bis 30 minuten
wir werden auf jeden fall dabei sein
wenn's losgeht bei uns verpassen sie
nichts und bis dahin wir reden wir mit
unseren spannenden gesprächs gästen wie
sie können uns ihre fragen oder ihre
statements schicken indem sie sie
einfach in die kommentarspalten
schreiben oder an die adresse melden die
sie jetzt hier hoffentlich gleich
eingeblendet sehen wir ihn später mit
der professorin christine falk von der
deutschen gesellschaft für immunologie
sie wird uns die ergebnisse dann
einschätzen und uns sagen was sie von
den beschlüssen hält wir werfen gleich
ein blick nach dänemark wo es ja den
freedom day so schon gab und sprechen
mit unserem korrespondenten herrmann
bernd und wir sprechen mit zdf
hauptstadtkorrespondenten nicole widmann
die in den letzten zwei jahren weiter
der ford alive ziemlich viele mpk runden
begleitet hallo nicole
hallo jessica nicole wir haben beide die
beschlussvorlage für die runde vorliegen
bevor wir die gleich auseinander nehmen
hat julia schröter noch einmal für uns
die wichtigsten punkte zusammengefasst
das schauen wir gleich mal drauf damit
wir alle denselben stand haben
in einem ersten schritt sollen private
zusammenkünfte für geimpfte und genesene
wieder ohne eine begrenzung der
teilnehmerzahl erlaubt sein anders sieht
es für ungeimpfte aus die bestehenden
einschränkungen für sie gelten weiter
bis zum 19 märz der zugang zum
einzelhandel soll künftig ohne kontrolle
möglich sein dabei muss mindestens eine
medizinische maske getragen werden
einigen bundesländern gilt auch rp zwei
masken pflicht ab dem 4 märz soll in
einem zweiten schritt weiter gelockert
werden dann gilt 3g für gastronomie und
übernachtungsgewerbe rein darf also wer
geimpft genesen oder getestet ist für
discos clubs und großveranstaltungen
gilt zweig plus also geimpft oder
genesen + test wege booster ist darf so
ein bei großveranstaltungen in
innenräumen gilt 60 prozent der
maximalen auslastung ist erlaubt aber
nicht mehr als 6000 zuschauende im
freien ist mehr drin 75 prozent
auslastung maximal 25.000 zuschauende
ab dem 20 märz sollen dann alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen
wegfallen wenn die lage in den
krankenhäusern das zulässt auch die home
office pflicht soll dann entfallen
nicole das ist jetzt nicht so ein
freedom day wie allen anderen ländern
ausgerufen wurde heute kam die nachricht
dass österreich jetzt an fünfter märz
fast alle regeln aufheben will die
schweiz schon morgen bei uns wird das
nicht so sein bei uns wird das er so
freedom step by step
genau das ist das worauf die zeichen
gerade stehen wenn es nach der fdp ginge
wären wir da auch schneller andere sagen
radikaler aber das ist jetzt dieser plan
das ist ja ganz interessant seit urlaub
stolz kanzler ist laufen diese mpk es ja
anders aha beide haben das ja auch schon
öfter hier gemacht und auch länger mal
abends gesessen und gewartet das was wir
jetzt gerade im stück von julia schröter
gesehen haben dass kursiert ja schon
seit tagen deswegen war die marschroute
klar man stimmt sich also vorher ab um
möglichst wenig am mpk tag selber zu
streiten und möglichst zügig zur sache
zu kommen und alle sind sich einig darin
dass es jetzt eine perspektive mit blick
auf den frühling auf den sommer also auf
wärmere temperaturen wir wissen das ist
der natürliche feind der o sohle geben
muss es muss jetzt die perspektiven
geben zum lockern ich hab's rat gesagt
zum einen eben einfach weil es möglich
ist wieder mehr im freien sein werden
aber was natürlich auch soweit dazu
gehört es ist verstehen landtagswahlen
an in einigen bundesländern und die
politik setzt darauf sich doch eher
beliebt zu machen mit lockerungs
perspektive und was denkst du über
welche punkte gibt es heute die größten
diskussionen denn so groß ist die
einigkeit am ende des tages haben oft
noch nicht
ja
ich habe ja gerade das wort perspektiven
schon genannt was auch interessant ist
das ist natürlich auch nach zwei
pandemie jahren großer unterschied zur
vorherigen regierung die ja mit einer
völlig neuen ausgangslage konfrontiert
war es ist auch eine perspektive drin in
dieser beschlussvorlage über die wir
gerade reden für den herbst man weiß
wenn die temperaturen wieder sinken wird
die lage wieder schwieriger und es gibt
unterschiedliche papiere eins aus dem
robert koch institut und es gibt auch
eines in england von dem gremium dass
die dortige regierung berät in den
szenarien durchgespielt werden was kann
passieren und in dem britischen papier
das wohl viel konkreter ist als das
deutsche aktuell geht es von der
optimistischen fall ist wir sind
tatsächlich mit der pandemie durch das
ist eine ende nie bis hin zur
pessimistischen
annahmen nämlich dass ein viel
schwereres ein wieder gefährlicheres
virus bzw eine gefährlichere variante
von cobit wieder auftaucht wie zum
beispiel delta ist ja wahr im vergleich
zur omikron dh man will sich mit dieser
beschlussvorlage auch darauf vorbereitet
man will besprechen wie gehen wir nach
dem sommer vor wenn sich die lage wieder
verschärfen sollte und da ist jetzt zu
hören
gibt es schwierigkeiten
interessanterweise wohl innerhalb der
ampel koalition weil da wohl auch die
fdp anscheinend ein lockerer rundkurs
fahren beziehungsweise jetzt erstmal
noch gar nicht mitziehen möchte wie
gesagt den fall jemand nach das ist noch
nicht fix und erstmal
er auf lockerung setzt statt auf
überlegungen die schon wie ein bisschen
den blick trüben könnten
ist natürlich klar dass niemand die die
stimmung irgendwie vermiesen will aber
natürlich wie du sagst mir nahm
gesundheitsminister lauterbach rechnet
ja ganz fest mit einer neuen welle im
herbst heißt es
was denkst du es geht ja vor allem darum
nicht wieder in so einer situation rein
zu rauschen in die wir jetzt diesen
herbst winter gekommen sind was könnten
da die maßnahmen seien
ja das ist eine gute frage also man muss
es ja gesetzlich irgendwie festlegen bzw
sich optionen hinlegen so jedenfalls
anscheinend der großteil der ampel oder
der meinung der ampel was tun wir wenn
und der berühmte werkzeugkasten dieses
wort haben wir in den letzten zwei
jahren ziemlich oft gehört der ist ja da
es wird vermutlich wieder darum gehen
instanzen zu definieren und maßnahmen zu
definieren die ab einer gewissen
incidents greifen will man die inzidenz
denn als das parameter betrachten dass
das weitere handeln bestimmt wir hatten
uns ja auch schon mal mit dem
hospitalisierung index zu tun der eine
zeit lang das maß der dinge sein sollte
beziehungsweise das handeln an leiten
sollte und was dann gemacht werden kann
haben wir gesehen kontakt beschränkungen
die ja im moment auch noch gelten
beschränkungen für den einzelhandel eine
test strategie ein test regime das
eventuell wieder hochgefahren wird im
moment hat sich ja gerade verändert dann
habe ich anrecht auf einen pcr-test also
da gibt es viele möglichkeiten und es
gibt sicherlich viele möglichkeiten die
noch gar nicht angedacht worden sind es
ist ja ein lernendes system wir alle
sind ja ein lernendes system in bezug
auf corona denn auch wenn es uns schon
ewig vorkommt das ist ja alles noch sehr
neu
absolut und ich glaube wir versprechen
nicht zu viel wenn wir sagen das wird
heute wahrscheinlich mal wieder eine der
spannenderen bund länder runden weil sie
einfach für uns alle wieder vieles
verändern wird und was genau das werden
wir dann gleich sehen nicole vielen dank
für den moment du bleibst jetzt die
ganze zeit bei uns und wir werden auch
später dann noch mal über die beschlüsse
reden wir wollen jetzt mal nach dänemark
schauen und dänemark at anfang februar
schon seinen freedom day und da möchte
ich gerne mit herrmann bernd im zdf
landesstudio kiel sprechen dass für die
berichterstattung in dänemark zuständig
ist hallo herr man grüße dich
ja wollen von der kieler förde kann man
ihr wart vor ein paar tagen in dänemark
und da wird jetzt keiner mehr nach
seinem impfstatus gefragt da werden
keine masken mehr getragen wie habt ihr
das erlebt ist das irgendwie so ein
stück parallelwelt
ja es ist schon bizarr also die dänische
grenze ist ja nicht weit weg nur gute
dreiviertel stunde mit dem auto 85 90
kilometer wir fahren da halt öfter mal
hin auch um die stimmung einzufangen
dänemark war ja immer so ein paar wochen
vor uns auch mit der aktuellen omikron
welle da ging es so richtig ende
november anfang dezember los alles so
ein bisschen mit zeitverzögerung und
jetzt ist teilt seit
februar die große öffnung und wenn man
durch die städte geht durch die
einkaufsstraßen ist es irgendwie alles
wie vor dem februar 2020 also es ist
sind bilder wie aus einer anderen welt
die cafés sind offen die leute sitzen
ohne maske dort in den geschäften ist
viel los und
man hat auch so den eindruck dass die
leute nach wie vor auch nach etwas mehr
als zwei wochen freedom day du hast das
gesagt sehr glücklich darüber sein
endlich als person korken aus der
flasche geflogen also die leute freuen
sich aber es mischt sich auch so ein
bisschen eine andere stimmung rein
vielleicht kann ich das gleich noch
erklären kann aber das wäre meine frage
gewesen dass er mit den menschen dort
gesprochen
wie stehen die hinter dieser aufhebung
der maßnahmen also gibt es da auch
kritische stimmen
ja es gibt vielleicht kann ich das so
beantworten es gibt eine aktuelle studie
eines forschers der heißt peter sind
kommt aus kopenhagen der hat das
verhalten der dänen während der ganzen
partie jetzt untersucht und das
auffällige und erstaunliche an dieser
untersuchung ist dass die dänen vor
große angst hatten dass das
gesundheitswesen implodiert diese angst
ist irgendwie weg sondern jetzt ist er
die angst dadurch extrem hohe
infektionszahlen also täglich ungefähr
45 1000 infizierte bei 6 millionen
einwohnern aktuell instanzen die bei
5.500 liegen jetzt ist die angst da dass
man sich selbst infizieren könnte und
diese angst ist er bei den jüngeren da
die natürlich auch viel mobiler sind die
älteren die auch sehr hohe impfquoten
vorweisen auch da noch vielleicht eine
zahl bei den über 60-jährigen liegt das
bei weit über 90 prozent also bei diesen
eher zurückhaltend also die angst sich
so infizieren ist bei den jungs
vorhanden und in diese gute stimmung
möchte sich so ein bisschen mulmiges
gefühl erwischt es mich jetzt wie sie es
aus und
gleichzeitig steigen auch die
todeszahlen wieder in dänemark was ja
wie modellierer vorausgesehen haben
werden warum es der regierung trotzdem
diesen schritt gegangen
ja die todeszahlen steigen aber sie
steigen natürlich nicht so rasant immer
im verhältnis und das hat auch mit dem
von mir eben erwähnten insolvenzen zu
tun also die experten sagen wenn sich so
viele menschen anstecken
fällt auch auf einmal in den
krankenhäusern auf dass es wesentlich
mehr menschen gibt die infiziert sind
die wegen ganz anderer beschwerden in
die krankenhäuser kam und man stellt
fest dass sie krone haben hier ja auch
in dänemark jetzt vorwiegend auch diese
ba2 variante also eine unter variante
von omikron und das wird als begründung
für die steigenden todeszahlen angegeben
aber es wird auch von der
gesundheitsbehörde gesagt das
gesundheitssystem ist stabil es gebe
eine entkoppelung zwischen den instanzen
und den einweisungen in die
krankenhäuser und genau diese
entkoppelung ist ja der hauptgrund für
die öffnung
andere skandinavische länder sind dem
modell von dänemark gefolgt an weitere
länder tun das auch gerade wir haben
gerade von österreich und der schweiz
gesprochen dann wäre das denn auch für
deutschland ein denkbares modell
ja es wird ja in teilen sogar
hier in schleswig-holstein
übertragen wir haben also hier im
nördlichsten bundesland der
bundesrepublik ähnliche impfquoten wie
in dänemark
dem krankenhaus belegung ist auch sehr
gering von daher könnte man das sagen
aber es gibt natürlich auch von experten
selbst in dänemark kritische stimmen ob
man nicht sommer 12 wochen zu zu schnell
geöffnet hat weil natürlich auch durch
die hohen instanzen auch deutlich mehr
menschen in die krankenhäuser kommen
zwar nicht in die intensivstation aber
sich mit ihren beschwerden melden und
einen vorteil haben die dänen uns
gegenüber wie ich finde sie haben ein
geniales digitales krankenhaus system
also so die digitale krankenakte
man weiß also bei den behörden exakt
bescheid wie es aussieht im land und
dann natürlich die deutlich niedrigere
einwohnerzahl als bei uns also
vergleiche sind da immer schwierig aber
ich sozusagen in der tendenz ist die
übertragbarkeit möglich trotz allem muss
man ja sagen dass in dänemark jetzt
diese durchseuchung eigentlich wirklich
teil der strategie ist um aus der
pandemie rauszukommen das ist ja
eigentlich genau das wovor in
deutschland wissenschaftler innen immer
warnen wie erklärst du diesen also wie
wiegt kann ein land das so sehen und das
andere land sieht es komplett anders
also ich würde es jetzt aus meiner sicht
und unter beobachtung jetzt in den
vergangenen zwei jahren so erklären
einmal ist es die von mir erwähnte
niedrigere einwohnerzahl 6 millionen und
jetzt kommt der erstaunliche zahlen die
wenige in deutschland kennen fast
zweieinhalb millionen dänen waren es
sind inzwischen mit corona infiziert und
der andere teil der bevölkerung
ist fast durchgehend also die haben eine
super quote von von fast 64 65 prozent
zwischen dh die gesundheitsbehörde sagt
wir haben hier eine grundimmunisierung
vorliegen und das ist glaube ich auch
der wesentliche faktor und der
wesentliche unterschied zu deutschland
und dänemark geht man ja dann sogar so
weit dass man sagt dass man jetzt so
langsam von einer impfkampagne abrücken
kann
ja auch das ist erstaunlich weil die
ministerpräsidentin sagt ja ihr ende
januar als sie den freedom day fast
euphorisch ankündigte ja einer der
hauptgründe für unseren erfolg ist die
gigantische
impfkampagne und
es gab auch keine proteste in der
bevölkerung also da sind die menschen in
skandinavien er irgendwie etwas
gelassener und cooler als bei uns habe
ich den eindruck aber
mein mein eindruck ist jetzt man sagt
okay wir haben diese grund immunität von
der sprache und die überlegung ist jetzt
man hat mal nachgedacht ja führte
impfungen für die älteren und auch
weiter boostern bei den jüngeren da geht
man von ab weil man jetzt bei der
gesundheitsbehörde und bei der politik
glaubt wir haben diese grund immunität
da können wir das langsam auch
zurückfahren was ich aber spannend finde
ist das was die kolleginnen aus berlin
die nicole eben sagte was ist dann im
herbst also da entdecke ich in dänemark
im moment auch keine strategie
vielen dank herr mann bernd für deine
schilderungen aus dänemark machs gut
viele nazis
also so weit der blick in ein land das
beschlossen hat dass corona dort kein
thema mehr sein soll bei uns ist das
noch nicht so und damit wieder zurück zu
nicole diekmann in berlin
auch hier noch mal ganz kurz der blick
nach dänemark wir haben es gerade gehört
in dänemark möchte man das kogit 19
keine gesellschafts bedrohende krankheit
mehr ist gibt es teilnehmende in dieser
bund länder runde heute nachmittag die
das auch so unterschreiben würden
na ja also das
noch mal kannst du die frage noch mal
stellen die habe ich glaube ich
inhaltlich nicht richtig verstanden in
dänemark ist es ja so dass man sagt 19
ist jetzt keine krankheit mehr die quasi
die gesellschaft in der existenziell
bedroht und ob es in dieser bund länder
runde die heute nachmittag zusammensitzt
leute gibt die sagen würden ja
unterschreibe ich so
ich glaube so weit würde meines wissens
nach niemand gehen der heute in der
runde sitzt aber wir haben es ja gerade
auch schon von meinem kollegen gehört
auf schleswig holstein
da will man weiter gehen als das was wir
gerade beschlossen wird oder wurde in
berlin laut erste anmeldung und sogar
die maske abschaffen ab ende märz
zumindest fast man das ins auge jetzt
muss man dazu aber wissen erstens haben
wir ja auch gerade schon gehört die
impfquote ist liegt über dem
bundesdurchschnitt in schleswig holstein
und
zweitens ist da die belegung der
krankenbetten ziemlich niedrig und
drittens das gehört auch dazu in
schleswig holstein wird gewählt das
heißt dass spielen also auch knallharte
politische interessen eine rolle das
trifft auch auf markus söder sowie
erinnern uns markus söder bayerischer
ministerpräsident lange team vorsicht
der große maler der sei es ja auch am
ende vieler mpk es dann vorne als
stellvertretender und
da der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei
den pressekonferenzen und hatte immer
die rolle desjenigen der warnte und
mahnte und dafür auch zum teil
kritisiert wurde als zu streng von
dieser position hat er sich inzwischen
verabschiedet und findet man müsse sich
jetzt mit einer veränderten lage auch
über veränderte maßnahmen sprich
lockerungen unterhalten omikron sein und
wirklich nicht zu vergleichen mit delta
auch markus söder möchte gewählt werden
kommendes jahr wird in bayern gewählt
und die umfragewerte von markus söder
zeigen die meisten menschen in bayern
goutieren seinen kurs nicht also da
sitzen heute durchaus leute am tisch die
relativ weit gehen wollen was
lockerungen angeht das heißt um die
wortschöpfung von ministerpräsident
söder noch mal zu bemühen da wird sich
dann voraussichtlich heute eher team
freiheit durchsetzen wir haben eine
frage von joachim keller auf facebook
warum denn ein stufenplan bei uns nur
geredet geredet geredet und andere
länder machen komplett auf
naja also über die vergleichbarkeit mit
anderen ländern haben wir ja eben auch
schon was gehört und
das ist natürlich auch dem umstand
geschuldet dass man dann erstmal gucken
möchte wie entwickelt sich denn dann
eigentlich die lage dass der eine grund
würde ich denken was passiert wenn wir
schritt 1 vollziehen also schritt eins
wäre ja zum beispiel das für geimpfte
und chinesen die kontakt beschränkung
wegfallen und im einzelhandel dann auch
der zweig status wegfällt sofern er
überhaupt noch besteht der ist ja auch
in einzelnen ländern schon gar nicht
mehr existent zum teil auch gekippt
worden
und zum anderen ganz einfach es wird
wärmer unser leben wird sich wieder
zunehmend nach draußen verlagern und wir
wissen je mehr wie draußen sind desto
schwerer hat corona ist sich weiter zu
verbreiten
es wären es ja eben gesehen in dem stück
von via schröter da ist die rede von
eröffnungs schritte neben in drei stufen
und dann hört man dann von 3g von 2g von
2g plus es wird das kann man glaube ich
jetzt schon sagen wieder eine große
herausforderung für die bürgerinnen und
bürger alles zu verstehen und die
veränderungen irgendwie dann auch parat
zu haben es klingt alles schon wieder
ein bisschen kompliziert
ja das ist es ja seit zwei jahren und
mit dem was du gerade gesagt hast hätten
wir eigentlich alle schon genug zu tun
aber es wäre ja fast schon ein kleines
wunder würde das was da heute
beschlossen wird sagen wir mal die
öffnungs schritte kommen jetzt eins zu
eins so wie wir sie eben im beitrag
gesehen haben es wäre ein wunder würde
es bundeseinheitlich dann auch komplett
so durchgezogen also
werkzeugkasten ist ja ein stichwort das
sich eben genannt habe das jetzt
wirklich schon sehr sehr oft gehört
haben das hat ja schon tricks
spielcharakter
und flickenteppich ist ja ein weiterer
begriff den wir in dieser pandemie
sehr oft gehört haben aber nicht sehr zu
schätzen gelernt haben weil die
unübersichtlichkeit dadurch natürlich
noch größer geworden ist und teilweise
ja auch es schwierig war dann die logik
überhaupt noch nachzuvollziehen warum
ist in einem land ist anders als in
anderen vor allem wenn leute hin und her
fahren wenn menschen pendeln beruflich
bedingt also von daher ja es wird
sicherlich nicht übersichtlich werden
das war es ja noch nie und wir sehen
hier gerade die pressekonferenz wir
sehen die leeren stühle dass sie noch
nicht begonnen hat und da würde ich
sagen dann nehmen wir uns doch kabel die
zeit und senden das stück von karl
hinterleitner der eben diese politische
diskussion und dieses hin und her
zusammengefasst hat
es geht um lockerungen und es geht um
gemeinsamkeit zwischen bund und ländern
da passte es nicht dass einzelne
frühzeitig vorpreschen so kippte berlin
die zwei gehwege im einzelhandel hamburg
kündigte das ende der sperrstunde an
alles vor der heutigen mpk und auch
bayern teilte gestern mit dass kontakt
beschränke und 5 chinesen nicht mit geld
und es schien als könnte es markus söder
nicht schnell genug gehen wir sind team
vorsicht und team freiheit aber nicht
team stur wir setzen deswegen heute auch
im bayerischen kabinett sowohl ein
signal in richtung der mpk aber machen
auch unsere eigenen maßnahmen trotz
solcher alleingänge sieht der
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
einigkeit der länder nicht gefährdet
wenn sie sich die regelung anschauen
dann sehen sie es ist ziemlich genau das
was wir jetzt besprechen was alle länder
jetzt machen werden an einigen stellen
laufen die verordnungen eben früher aus
die kabinette tagen aber wir sind da
ziemlich gleichmäßig unterwegs die
rechtsgrundlage der korona maßnahmen das
infektionsschutzgesetz läuft am 19 märz
aus ein freedom day an dem alle regeln
fallen soll danach aber nicht kommen das
virus richtet sich nicht nach dem
kalender wir müssen achtsam bleiben auch
nach dem 19 deswegen sollten wir eben
nicht alles über bord werfen was sich in
den letzten monaten bewährt hat hendrik
wüst und andere sprechen sich auch für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht aus sowie
für eine erhöhung der impfquote die sei
nötig damit das land auch weitere
varianten des virus vorbereitet ist
es bleibt kompliziert stichwort ihm
pflicht was gerade angesprochen wurde
wie will sich die runde da heute
positionieren
ja das ist eine der wenigen eckigen
klammern die noch in der
beschlussvorlage zu sehen ist in diesem
eckigen klammern die ja immer ein
zeichen dafür sind das noch etwas
strittig ist beziehungsweise noch nicht
wirklich einigkeit erzielt worden ist in
den gesprächen vor dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da findet
sich das wort ins register das ist jetzt
ein vorstoß aus der union ein
impf register zu schaffen das bedeutet
es wird zentral da klingeln ja auf die
alarmglocken bei uns deutschen stichwort
datenschutz für zentral so die
vorstellung erfasst bei den
krankenkassen zum beispiel wer ist
geimpft wer ist wie oft geimpft wer
müsste mal wieder geimpft werden wer es
überhaupt noch nicht gehen und dann gibt
es eben den vorschlag sollen diejenigen
über 18 zimmer über 18 jähriger
angeschrieben werden kontaktiert werden
und dann informiert werden
beziehungsweise dazu bewogen werden
geimpft zu werden die impfpflicht war ja
mal
oder sagen wir es anders die impfpflicht
hat ja eine sehr abenteuerliche
geschichte jetzt schauen sie ist
kategorisch ausgeschlossen worden im
wahlkampf dann
wurden diese versprechen tatsächlich
gebrochen von der politik da hieß es
dann auf einmal doch wir brauchen
dienstlich das waren veränderte
vorzeichen keine frage aber das
versprechen wahr gemacht worden ohne
große not und da hatten viele zurück den
längsten weg hatte da die fdp zurück zu
legen die damit auch wahlkampf gemacht
hatte und nun wackelt diese im licht
wieder
und nun wie gesagt gibt es zum beispiel
eben diesen vorschlag des imf registers
um darüber dann
tja die menschen an zu schreiben und
dann das problem vielleicht erstmal zu
verlagern bzw das thema zu verlagern das
steht heute also auch auf der
tagesordnung wie gesagt mit eckigen
klammern aber was eben auch in der
beschlussvorlage steht ist impfen hilft
es gibt ja jedesmal das werden wir auch
heute sehen auf der pressekonferenz
wieder den appell an alle bürgerinnen
und bürger sich impfen zu lassen denn
die impfkampagne in deutschland läuft ja
nicht so wie sie laufen sollte es geht
ja jetzt vor allem im moment in der
debatte um die sogenannten arabien
gruppen um die menschen ab 60 da sind
drei millionen menschen noch nicht
vollständig geimpft und ich habe heute
morgen noch mal nachgeguckt
2,8 millionen von denen also der
überwiegende teil ist noch nicht mal
zwei mal geben das heißt wir reden da
nicht von leuten die die booster impfung
vielleicht einfach noch nicht haben
vornehmen lassen sondern die tatsächlich
nicht geimpft sind und da ist die sorge
eben groß dass man die
sollte eine neue welle kommen nicht
vernünftig schützen kann
die
impfpflicht wird hier genannt in der
beschlussvorlage und dann steht der
halterin bund und länder werden weiter
intensiv für das impfen werben und
leicht zu erreichen die info angebote
machen man hat so ein bisschen den
eindruck so langsam gehen gehen die
ideen aus für die impfkampagne kann das
sein wie siehst du das ja das sieht so
aus das sieht so aus also urlaub scholz
hatte als kanzler ja auch versprechen
gemacht zahlen genannt konkrete zahlen
das machen politik hat ja eigentlich
nicht so gerne ziele tatsächlich
so klar zu definieren denn dann ist auch
sehr klar nachzuweisen wenn solche ziele
nicht erreicht worden sind und das
musste er relativ schnell einräumen dass
also die zahl der booster impfung zu dem
zeitpunkt der genannt hatte
nicht vorgenommen worden waren
also von daher ist bleibt bei appellen
sonst würden wir über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht jetzt ja auch gerade gar
nicht miteinander sprechen und selbst
die wackelt ja inzwischen ganz gewaltig
wir sehen dass die pressekonferenz immer
noch nicht begonnen hat wir werden
sofort rüber gehen nach berlin wenn es
dann losgeht
wir kennen das mittlerweile dass wir da
viel geduld haben müssen aber es gibt ja
auch vieles zu besprechen
ich werde gerne noch mal zwei punkte mit
der durchgehenden relativ spät noch in
diese beschlussvorlage
reinkamen das eine ist punkt 8 und da
geht es dass jetzt jemand gerade durchs
bild gelaufen deshalb war ich schon ganz
aufgeregt aber nein das geht noch nicht
los soll aber gleich losgehen vielleicht
können wir diese frage noch klären es
geht um den genießenden status der jetzt
noch mal überarbeitet werden sollen und
jetzt sehe ich wir gehen jetzt rüber
nach berlin im kanzleramt
bundeskanzler scholz tritt vor und
nach
meine damen meine herren ich darf sie
herzlich begrüßen zur pressekonferenz
nach der zusammenkunft des
bundeskanzlers mit den regierungschefin
und regierungschefs der länder ich darf
neben bundeskanzler olaf schulz den
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst und die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin hat sich der
gefahr hier begrüßen und wie üblich
beginnt der bundeskanzler
meine damen und herren wir befinden uns
sondern ganz besonderen tag der pandemie
wir können zuversichtlich nach vorne
schauen als wir das die letzten wochen
konnten wir haben in den letzten wochen
und monaten entscheidungen getroffen die
dazu beigetragen haben dass deutschland
im verhältnis zu seinen nachbarländern
viel besser durch die aktuelle
virus infektionswelle gekommen ist die
infektionen sind bei uns später erst
gestiegen auch die infektionen die mit
der nikon variante zusammenhängen der
scheitelpunkt ist mittlerweile wohl
erreicht alle anzeichen die wir haben
sprechen dafür dass genau zu dem
zeitpunkt unsere zusammenkunft wie
vorhergesehen das gelungen ist und wir
können davon ausgehen dass wenn alles so
bleibt wie wir das gegenwärtig
voraussehen können wir in den nächsten
wochen eine stetig verbesserte situation
haben was gelungen ist dass es weniger
männer und frauen gibt die auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen als das ohne alle unsere
maßnahmen der fall gewesen wäre das
gelungen ist ist wie gesagt dass die
infektionen geringer gestiegen sind und
deshalb können wir glaube ich sagen dass
wir mit unseren maßnahmen erreicht haben
was wir wollten gesundheit und leben der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen einen
lock down zu vermeiden und mit denen
dann aber doch getroffenen kontakt
beschränken dazu beizutragen dass genau
diese situation von uns jetzt
festgestellt werden die wir haben also
ein gutes zeichen die letzten wochen und
monate haben die länder und der bund
gemeinsam
offenbar die richtigen entscheidungen
getroffen
das ist jetzt auch die grundlage dafür
dass wir
optimistische perspektiven auf machen
können und für die zeit bis zum
frühlingsanfang jetzt in drei schritten
stück für stück einen großen teil der
beschränkung die gegenwärtig noch in
deutschland gelten zurücknehmen dazu
haben sich die länder und der bund
miteinander verabredet und wollen das
koordiniert zwischen den ländern und dem
bund in den nächsten tagen und wochen
auch stück für stück vollziehen ich
halte das für einen guten fortschritt es
geht ja vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern
sowie mir irgendwie haben wir nach all
diesen langen zwei jahren zwei jahren ob
man
verdient dass es irgendwie wieder besser
wird und es sieht ein bisschen danach
aus dass wir genau das auch vor uns
haben wir dürfen bei all dem optimismus
und der zuversichtlich wir hier
verzeichnen nicht unvorsichtig werden
deshalb muss man auch klar sagen die
pandemie ist eben noch nicht vorbei die
infektionszahlen sind eben hoch und wir
sehen jetzt nur dass sie wohl demnächst
runtergehen und
deshalb gilt auch immer noch dass wir
alle
noch überzeugen müssen die sich bisher
nicht haben impfen lassen impfung hilft
und schützt am meisten vor den folgen
der infektion
und dass wir jetzt im verhältnis zu
vielen anderen besser durch die omikron
welle gekommen sind nicht natürlich auch
daran dass wir viele geimpfte haben wenn
auch nicht genug und dass sehr viele
gepustet sind im vergleich zu anderen
ziemlich viele und dass beides muss
fortgesetzt werden deshalb wollen wir
jetzt und auch in den nächsten wochen
und monaten weiter machen mit impfungen
erstimpfung zweite empfunden und
auffrischungsimpfung und wir bitten alle
dass sie diese entscheidung für sich
treffen der pigs hilft eben
außerdem wissen wir dass wir vorsorge
treffen müssen für die zeit wenn der
frühling angefangen hat und all die
maßnahmen die wir bisher an
beschränkungen ergriffen haben
überwiegend nicht mehr gelten dass das
was notwendig ist dann auch noch
ergriffen werden kann als entscheidung
der länder und der dort der zuständigen
behörden das gilt für maske und
abstandhalten bestimmten rahmen und
viele viele andere maßnahmen
die sind hier in dem beschluss
aufgeschrieben und ich zusammen mit der
bundesregierung und den anderen werde
mich dafür verwenden dass entsprechend
dieses beschlusses in den
gesetzgebungsprozess
der jetzt einsetzt im bundestag auch
diese anliegen für die zeit nach dem
frühlingsbeginn und nach auslaufen der
meisten maßnahmen
aufgegriffen werden dass
handlungsfähigkeit erhalten bleibt und
wir vorbereitet sind für das was uns
begegnen kann denn ich habe es gesagt
die pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei und
es kann deshalb die nächste variante um
die ecke kommen und uns vor ganz neue
herausforderungen stellen und dann
müssen wir etwas tun können und das ist
auch richtig wir hatten heute auch
erneut
ein vertreter des expertengremiums dabei
fair und sorgfältig geschildert habe das
doktorat ist und er ist auch genauso wir
können das mit den öffnungszeiten die
wir jetzt machen wagen wir müssen
vorsorge treffen für die zeit in der
nacht das gilt insbesondere für maske
und abstand und manche andere maßnahmen
und wir müssen weiter für das impfen
werben und genau das wollen wir alles
machen
gestartet wir noch die persönliche
bemerkung dass ich glaube dass wir
trotz der zuversicht trotz der tatsache
dass wir jetzt in den frühling hinein
kommen wo wir viele beschränkungen
hinter uns lassen und sache besser wird
nicht vergessen dürfen dass es auch den
nächsten herbst und winter gibt und
deshalb bleibt es richtig nicht nur
weiter fürs impfen zu werben sondern
auch die gesetzgebungs maßnahmen im
hinblick auf eine allgemeine impfpflicht
vorzubereiten sie wird genau dann
notwendig sein wenn das wetter wieder
kälter wird denn die zeit wieder dunkler
wird und wenn die infektion wieder
zunehmen kann und das ist die aufgabe
die wir dann auch noch von zahlen vielen
dank
als nächstes
der vielen dank wir stehen in der tat an
einer stelle an dem wir
verantwortungsvoll und vorausschauend
eröffnungs perspektiven schaffen können
und rechts eingriffe zurücknehmen können
wir müssen dabei öffnungen und
achtsamkeit miteinander verbinden es
besteht derzeit grund zur hoffnung dass
sich die omikron welle langsam
zurückziehen wird eine überlastung des
grund des gesundheitssystems ist aus
sicht der experten derzeit nicht zu
befürchten deswegen befinden wir uns
jetzt in einer neuen phase der pandemie
das heißt öffnungen werden möglich die
rücknahme von grundrechtseingriffen
möglich aber wir müssen eben auch in
dieser phase achtsamen bleiben das
bedeutet vor allen dingen das
verantwortungsvolle öffnungs
perspektiven verbunden sein müssen mit
einem guten basisschutz wenn der
bundestag nicht aktiv handelt laufen ab
dem 20 märz alle schutzmaßnahmen aus den
fällen schlicht alle maßnahmen die wir
bisher noch kennen weg anime richtet
sich aber nicht nach dem kalender
wir dürfen deshalb nicht alles
hopplahopp über bord werfen was sich in
den letzten monaten bewährt hat uns ja
auch zu dem von bundeskanzler gerade
zurecht erwähnten erfolgen geführt hat
alle länder sind sich deshalb einig dass
wir einen basisschutz brauchen um die
öffnungen abzusichern auch über den
frühlingsanfang hinaus der verhindert
dass die infektionszahlen dann wieder
steigen und im falle eines anstiegs der
infektionszahlen sofort auch verfügbar
ist aus sicht der länder brauchen wir
deshalb aus der sammlung der bewährten
schutzmaßnahmen insbesondere masken
pflicht
abstandsregeln hygiene konzepte test und
zumindest die möglichkeit in besonders
gefährdeten bereichen testpflicht zum
nachweispflichten vorzusehen hier geht
es immer darum dass wir eine
rechtsgrundlage dafür brauchen die man
dann natürlich nur zieht wenn sie
wirklich notwendig ist
einige dieser möglichkeiten brauchen wir
im übrigen auch für einen stabilen schul
und kita betrieb die länder haben die
bundesregierung gebeten für den
basisschutz eine sichere rechtsgrundlage
zu schaffen damit wir eben jederzeit
handlungsfähig wären wenn notwendig auch
wenn der bundeskanzler den katalog in
summe jetzt nicht förmlich mittragen
konnte bin ich ihnen doch dankbar auch
für seine gerade getätigte aussage dass
er sich innerhalb der koalition im bund
persönlich für diese vorstellung der
länder einsetzen will wir haben respekt
vor den mehrheiten hier im parlament
aber lassen wir auch sagen es hat sich
in den letzten monaten der pandemie
immer bewährt wenn bund und länder eng
zusammengearbeitet haben auch wenn es
hier und da mal schwierig wurde und das
ist auch beim basisschutz wichtig
brauchen verlässlichkeit und klarheit in
der pandemie politik das gilt auch bei
fragen wie viele monate ein mensch sein
genesenen status hat das hin und her in
den letzten wochen war nicht gut es hat
viele menschen verunsichert und das muss
beendet werden solche entscheidungen
können auch nicht einfach auf der
homepage vom rk ii das sich ansonsten
sehr schätze kommuniziert werden ohne
dass irgendjemand da vorher nochmal
drauf guckt deshalb sollen die regeln
zum genesenen status in zukunft wieder
in einem geordneten verfahren der
rechtssetzung
erfolgen geht darum dass die regeln
praktikabel und umsetzbar sind deswegen
müssen dabei auch die länder die länder
rechte gewahrt sein achtsamkeit heißt
auch öffnungen zwischendurch zu
überprüfen wir haben ja die schritte
gemacht damit zwischendurch 14 tage zeit
ist in denen man schauen kann und so
haben wir es auch
verabredet in beide richtungen schauen
kann ob die maßnahmen lage angemessen
sind klarer kurs ist hier wichtig die
öffnungen sind
richtig ich hätte mir aber gewünscht
dass wir uns zu der frage
gehen wir den nächsten schritt oder
müssen wir vielleicht umkehren auch
terminlich konkret verabredet hätten
wenn es wäre nicht klug jetzt zu lockern
und dann ist einfach weiterlaufen zu
lassen sind selbst selten unterwegs
sichtbar wird das vielleicht ein
bisschen tempo rausnehmen wichtig werden
wir müssen achtsam bleiben um die ersten
schritte der öffnungen nicht zu
gefährden wir müssen achtsam bleiben
weil gerade besonders schutzbedürftige
personen gruppen von schweren verläufen
betroffen sind und auch in zukunft
betroffen sein können wir müssen achtsam
bleiben weil in teilen deutschlands die
ältere bevölkerung nicht über einen so
hohen impfschutz verfügt wie in anderen
ländern
und deshalb möchte ich hier auch nochmal
ausdrücklich sagen neben dem basisschutz
muss weiterhin gelten impfen impfen dass
die zweite leitplanke für die
eröffnungsauktion und für die eröffnungs
schritte wir müssen weiterhin gemeinsam
daran arbeiten die impflücken zu
schließen auch mit blick auf den im
herbst der expertenrat hat uns dazu auch
klare hinweise gegeben dass damit zu
rechnen ist dass die pandemie eben nicht
vorbei ist das impfen bleibt der
richtige weg raus aus der pandemie und
um menschenleben zu schützen wir reden
ja viel über diejenigen die durchs ganze
land spazieren gehen ich will mal über
die reden die zum impfen gehen ist ein
starker beitrag zur solidarität und
freiheit für alle und auch deshalb sage
ich allen die sie haben ihn verlassen
und sich jetzt vielleicht ist auch
kurzfristig überlegen ganz herzlichen
dank dafür und
herren heute ist ein wichtiger schritt
und auch ein neuer schritt gegangen
worden ein dreisprung den wir vereinbart
haben in drei schritten eben vorzugehen
für die öffnungs perspektiven das ist
etwas was sie erwartet wird in der
bevölkerung und was ich auch glücklicher
weise durch die aktuell abflachende
omikron welle und die tatsache dass wir
den scheitelpunkt erreicht
beziehungsweise überschritten haben auch
rechtfertigen und deshalb ist es
notwendig das eben in dem moment wo die
lage sich entspannt wo die situation in
den krankenhäusern auf den
intensivstationen
beherrschbar ist auch in einen anderen
bereichen der kritischen infrastruktur
das will ich ganz deutlich sagen denn
darum ging es uns immer die kritische
infrastruktur im gesundheitsbereich und
darüber hinaus zu sichern wenn diese
situation beherrschbar ist und sich
entspannt dann ist es notwendig auch
schritte der verhältnismäßigkeit zu
gehen schritte der rücknahme von
einschränkungen schritte von öffnungen
und lockerungen und dies
verantwortungsvoll zu tun das ist schon
deutlich geworden deshalb her ist heute
für den schritt eins eben die lockerung
bei privaten zusammenkünften beschlossen
worden auch das was dir jetzt bei gehege
im einzelhandel bedrückt das ja schon in
vielen bundesländern auch im vorgriff
der heutigen ministerpräsidenten
konferenz umgesetzt oder vorbereitet
worden ist die rücknahme von 2g im
einzelhandel und die ersetzung dieser
regelung durch die ffw zwei maske eine
sehr diskutierte maßnahmen die heute
beschlossen worden ist generell als
regelung im ersten schritt und daneben
in schritt zwei ab dem 4 märz die
lockerungen und die dreijährigen für
gastronomie und hotellerie lockerungen
für diskotheken und flugs und andere
tanz lustbarkeiten aber auch weitere
öffnungs perspektiven und erweiterte
perspektiven für die großveranstaltung
und dann eben mit dem 20 märz dann der
wegfall der tiefgreifenden
schutzmaßnahmen das sind schritte auf
die wir uns sehr sehr einvernehmlich
verständigt haben es ist gut dass das
stufenweise geschieht das eben nicht von
einem tag auf den anderen dinge
verändert werden sondern dass wir jetzt
einen klaren plan haben einen klaren
plan für die nächsten vier wochen klare
perspektiven die wir auch kommunizieren
wollen und die nachvollziehbar sind für
die bevölkerung und daneben aber auch
und das hat kollege wüster dargestellt
die perspektive über den 20 märz hinaus
wenn wir uns jetzt auf diese wegstrecke
auf diese reise begeben hin zu mehr
öffnung hin zur rückkehr in die
normalität dann ist es wichtig dass wir
auch über den 2 märz hinaus den
sprichwörtlichen sandkasten im
kofferraum haben der eben sichert das
wenn ein notfall geschieht wir sofort
handlungsfähig sind und das ist ein
großes anliegen der länder dass heute
auch geäußert worden ist die
handlungsfähigkeit im notfall die
handlungsfähigkeit wenn wir ein
ausbruchsgeschehen haben die
handlungsfähigkeit in bestimmten
situationen eben klar zu sagen es gibt
regelungen für die maske es gibt
regelungen für die tests und es gibt
auch regelungen für nachweispflichten
getestet genesen geimpft das wird nötig
sein als phases instrumentarium dass wir
sehr zügig diese möglichkeiten auch
haben und regional bezogen dann diese
schritte auch gehen können und mit
diesem sany kasten im kofferraum können
wir uns optimistisch verantwortungsvoll
verhältnismäßig und wirksam auf den weg
machen und wir können diese schritte
diese wichtigen perspektiven nicht nur
aufzeigen sondern sie auch umsetzen
deshalb ist heute wirklich ein guter tag
für
die perspektive der kommenden wochen ich
bin sehr froh darüber dass wir diese
beschlüsse so gefasst haben es wird
jetzt darum gehen dass der umfang der
basis schutzmaßnahmen auch dann im
bundestag durch bundesgesetzgebung
entsprechend geregelt wird dass wir eben
ein mindest instrumentarium nach dem 20
märz auch in den ländern unmittelbar in
der hand haben das wird jetzt geschehen
wir begrüßen das sehr und ich glaube
dass wir mit diesen klaren regelungen
jetzt auch den verschiedenen branchen in
der wirtschaft gerade denen die
besonders gelitten haben auch unter den
einschränkungen heute hier auch ein ganz
klares zeichen für den aufbruch für den
neustart senden können rückenwind für
die kommende und beginnende
frühjahrssaison und dass wir auch und
das will ich auch noch mal ganz
besonders betonen die kinder und
jugendlichen im blick haben diejenigen
die jetzt natürlich und diesen
einschränkungen auch viele würden
hinnehmen mussten das hat die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute auch
noch mal deutlich gemacht mit einem teil
der beschlussfassung dass eben gerade
die bedingungen für die kinder und
jugendlichen eben für uns wichtig sind
und dass in den kommenden folge
schritten die in den ländern umgesetzt
werden natürlich auch und gerade die
folgen und die wirkung der
einschränkungen für kinder und
jugendliche berücksichtigt werden und
das bei allen öffnungs und
lockerungsschritte neben alle
altersgruppen gleichermaßen zu
berücksichtigen sind das finde ich
wichtig und deshalb wird es sicherlich
auch zur frage der schulsituation der
kita situation in den ländern darüber
hinausgehende regelung geben das ist ja
in der mpk nicht gegenstand die
einzelregelungen dafür zu treffen aber
vorsorge zu treffen mit eben dem
basisschutz paket auch für den bereich
der kitas und der schulen darauf haben
wir uns verständigt dass das genau so
eben in diesen bereichen gilt und
insofern glaube ich dass wir hier heute
ein klares signal für die nächsten vier
wochen setzen können für den ablauf aber
auch darüber hinaus vereinbarungen
getroffen haben wie ermöglicht werden
kann dass die länder die notwendigen
handlungsmöglichkeiten auch über den
märz hinaus dann haben werden
47 wortmeldungen die erste wortmeldung
hat michael fischer von dpa
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler zunächst
eine verständnis frage zu den
großveranstaltungen
werden da nach dem 20 märz auch noch
teilnehmer beschränkungen möglich sein
oder im klartext werden ab dem 20 märz
tatsächlich die fußballstadien in
deutschland wieder bis zum letzten platz
gefüllt werden können und dann würde
mich interessieren welche auswirkungen
der lockerung sie auch die debatte über
die impfpflicht
sehen
befürchten sie dass eine normalisierung
des öffentlichen lebens die akzeptanz
für diese impfpflicht möglicherweise
beschränken könnte sie werden finden
dass wir nach dem mit dem
frühlingsanfang und nach
dem zwanzigsten auch noch basis
schutzmaßnahmen hand als
handlungsmöglichkeit aufrechterhalten
wollen aber nicht als standard regel
sondern als das was dann ist das ist ja
doch jetzt ist die mutige
zuversichtliche optimistischen prognose
die 16 länder und die bundesregierung
gemeinsam haben dass wir es wagen können
tatsächlich das meiste zu öffnen
trotzdem brauchen wir danach noch die
möglichkeit zu handeln wenn das passiert
und wie das gemacht wird darüber wird
jetzt konkret im einzelnen gesprochen
und dazu stehen hier einzelne vorschläge
in dem beschluss drin und die rechtliche
grundlage soll rechtzeitig vor dem
zwanzigsten existieren aber das will ich
ihnen gerne sagen das meiste wird dann
so sein
es ist da kaum beschränkungen sind und
abstand und masken werden die
wichtigsten regeln seien die wir haben
ein paar andere werden wir noch brauchen
und vor allem situativ brauchen also
wenn dann plötzlich ein ausbruch da ist
wenn in einem landkreis eine situation
entsteht wo zum beispiel eine großes
infektionsgeschehen ist dann muss man
was tun und diese instrumente möglich zu
machen darüber findet jetzt gesetzgebung
stadt und die wollen wir auch
rechtzeitig abschließend vor dem
zwanzigster märz da war noch eine zweite
frage in flieden
nein die impfpflicht ist notwendig für
den nächsten herbst und winter das habe
ich gesagt wir werden jetzt
nicht noch eine neue variante alles
durcheinanderbringt wenn da nicht noch
irgendeine andere variante des virus um
die ecke kommt werden wir jetzt
tatsächlich an frühling erleben und ein
sommer in dem die meisten beschränkungen
die wir haben unseren alltag nicht mehr
beeinträchtigen und das ist auch gut und
wenn ich das mal sagen darf gibt es für
uns drei und bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes sowie für alle anderen wir
sehen uns auch danach dass das so ist
und
gleichzeitig müssen wir vorsichtig
bleiben deshalb brauchen wir die
möglichkeit was du tun wenn es notwendig
wird und masken dann auch danach noch
eine rolle spielen
und deshalb brauchen wir natürlich auf
die vorbereitung auf den herbst und
winter und dazu ist das mit der
impfpflicht unverändert wichtig will ich
noch mal festhalten die einigkeit die 16
länder und der bundeskanzler in dieser
frage haben besteht fort wir finden zu
17 das was richtig ist und da macht
dafür und bin auch zuversichtlich
das nicht sagt er ist dadurch andreas
kienast
vielen dank eine frage zum genesenen
status herr bundeskanzler indem sie dem
robert koch institut die zuständigkeit
jetzt wieder entziehen entziehen sie
damit nicht auch lothar wieler
öffentlich das vertrauen und ist das
heute vielleicht auch so der moment wo
sie sagen da haben wir einen fehler
gemacht und herr wüst die länder wollten
die entscheidung über den genießenden
status ja dem bundesrat überlassen
vielleicht können sie nochmal sagen
warum und ja wie es ausgegangen heute
ich habe großes vertrauen dass das
wirklich eine seit jahrzehnten wirklich
wichtige institutionen in unserem land
ist und herr wille hat wirklich eine
ganz verdienstvolle arbeit geleistet und
leistet sie unverändert die in dieser
pandemie von großer bedeutung ist und
das geht hier nicht um das erkannt und
darum dass wir uns als staat miteinander
verständigt haben dass angesichts der
großen bedeutung die das hat solche
festlegungen zu treffen die auf dem
gesetzlich
weitreichendsten niveau stattfinden
sollen und die beratung die gegenwärtig
vorbereitet werden sonst sind so dass
wir jedenfalls die
delegation auf eine webseite
aufheben wollen und dadurch dass im
gesetz regeln und auch sicherstellen
dass beschränkungen die verbürgen und
bürger dann wegen neuer erkenntnisse
zusätzlich eintreten könnten das wäre es
nicht hoffnung nicht annehmen aber das
ist ja das was der hintergrund der frage
ist dass die dann nicht einfach
durch dieses delegation diese verweisung
stattfinden kann sondern
dass das dann immer ein verfahrens und
dem viele beteiligte und das wird jetzt
gewährleistet wann
glauben sie mir vorher einen satz zu
sagen der bürger wüst freut sich auf
manche einschränkungen die wegfällt der
politiker wüst und ich glaube ich auch
für uns alle drei hat auch die variablen
gruppen im blick
und ist deswegen auf achtsamkeit in der
öffnung bedacht zum thema gelesen status
das war das alte verfahren das der
bundesrat zustimmungspflichtig war man
wollte ein schnelleres verfahren dieses
schnellere verfahren hat dann zu den
dingen geführt die wir in den letzten
wochen gesehen haben die über die auch
alle unglücklich sind
zwischenzeitlich hatte es noch eine
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung dazu
gegeben so dass es jetzt den plan gibt
es im gesetz zu regeln
mir ist wichtig und das haben wir heute
auch festgehalten gemeinsam dass die
länderrechte dabei gewahrt werden und
das werden wir jetzt im
gesetzgebungsverfahren auch beachten
dass das in der praktischen umsetzung
nachher zu gewährleistet ist
nächstes auf der liste sei
vielen dank ich hätte genau ich habe
zwei fragen wenn sie erlauben einmal zur
impfpflicht um die frage vielleicht auch
an sie drei gerichtet aus der union gab
es ja jetzt erhebliche zweifel dass
einer der vorschläge also einer der
anträge eine mehrheit im parlament
bekommen könnte sehen sie das oder wie
schätzen sie das ein und an sie herr
wüst sehen sie das auch so teilen sie
diese auffassung und dann eine frage zum
im krieg ist wenn ich das richtig sehe
wurde das aus der beschlussvorlage
rausgestrichen warum hat man sich dazu
entschieden vielen dank
wenn ich die zusammensetzung oder die
parteibücher der ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten angucken dann sind
da welche
und spd von den grünen
an der cdu und der csu
und alle sind gemeinsame meinung das ist
eine impfpflicht geben sollte
da sollten wir uns doch
bundeskanzler und 16 ministerpräsidenten
zusammen zutrauen dass wir dafür auch
eine mehrheit bekommen und dafür
politisch werben indem wir das jetzt
nicht zu einem thema machen und den
üblichen politischen ränkespiele eine
rolle spielen und der eine guckt wird in
dem anderen am meisten das antun kann
sondern wie wir das tun was an
verantwortung gegenüber
unseren bürgern an bürgern haben und
diese verantwortung sagt dass wir das
machen das sehen ja auch die meisten
bürgern und bürger so deshalb gehe ich
einfach davon aus dass alle mit denen
ich heute zusammen geredet habe
mithelfen dass wir das hinkriegen da bin
ich ganz zuversichtlich was das register
betrifft ist das so dass ist eine
diskussion darüber gibt ob man so etwas
grundsätzlich braucht also die frage
müssen wir irgendwie an der
elektronisch also eine daten absicherung
haben der impfung auf die man zugreifen
kann das ist eine diskussion die
technisch kompliziert ist und die
aufregende zeit in anspruch nehmen wir
für die frage endlich müssen wir
möglichkeiten nutzen so sehe ich das
jedenfalls die wir haben ohne ein
solches register dass wir jetzt ja gar
nicht zu verfügung stellen können so
schnell und da gibt es ja
gesetzgebungsvorschläge die sich darüber
schon für sich selbst abschließende
gedanken gemacht haben es ging also auch
ohne und darum ist das jetzt aus der
sicht ebenfalls teils derjenigen die da
diskutiert haben nicht erforderlich
gewesen das zu erwähnen also die
impfpflicht es das richtige darum sonst
gehen
vielen dank für die frage
die experten haben heute der expertenrat
dort noch einmal vorgetragen dass das
impfen wichtig ist dass die impfung die
richtige art der immunisierung ist auch
mit blick auf den herbst und lage der
dinge werden wir eine ausreichende
durchimpfung der bevölkerung ohne eine
impfpflicht nicht erreichen
das ist fakt was ist genauso fakt das
ist eine solche vielzahl von gruppen
anträgen gibt oder geben soll wenn ich
richtig im bilde bin gibt es mindestens
einen angekündigt noch nicht dass nach
lage der dinge im bundestag bisher keine
andere keiner dieser anträge eine
mehrheit insofern ist die schlichte
feststellung richtig ich habe für die
unionsgeführten bundesländer zum
vergangenen monat angeboten dass wir zu
gesprächen bereit sind und die unions
bundestagsfraktion hat das durch den
parlamentarischen geschäftsführern
gestrigen tage auch noch einmal gemacht
wir sind nicht am ende der
meinungsfindung mehrheitsfindung im
deutschen bundestag
dann als nächstes anträge von reuters
danke schön herr bundeskanzler ich
wollte noch mal zum basisschutz fragen
sie haben eben in ihrem
eingangsstatement
vorsichtig gesagt sie werden sich dafür
verwenden dass die gesetzliche grundlage
geschaffen wird deswegen hatte ich ganz
gerne noch mal nachgefragt sind sie ganz
sicher oder haben sie die zusicherung
der fdp die einmal von einem freedom day
gesprochen hatte der jetzt am
zwanzigsten
basisschutz danach noch gibt vielleicht
nicht in der form kommt haben sie die
zusicherung ihres koalitionspartners
dass er das im gesetzgebungsverfahren
auch mitmacht und eine frage an die
beiden länder vertreter und drin
ist die neue phase die sie beschrieben
haben nicht eigentlich eine neue
abwägung zwischen mehrheits wünschen
nach lockerungen und minderheiten lasten
denn in dem papier das sie verabschiedet
haben wird ja selber erwähnt und der
expertenrats hatte hat das auch getan
dass die zahl der intensivpatienten über
60 wieder steigen wird also ist das
nicht eine seltsame gleichzeitigkeit
dass sie einerseits die schutzmaßnahmen
loben und sie gleichzeitig abbauen
wir müssen immer wissen wo wir stehen
wir haben jetzt reicht es den
vollständigen impfschutz wie er heute
definiert wird 75 prozent der
bevölkerung haben also die mindestens
zwei impfungen haben das ist schon ganz
schön viel die zahl derjenigen die
auffrischungsimpfung haben damit auch
ständig zu und wir wissen gleichzeitig
dass wir aber nicht da sind wo wir
hinkriegen kommen müssen andere länder
in europa haben
85 oder noch mehr prozent
und ich habe gerade mit der dänischen
ministerpräsidenten getroffen gehabt die
hat eine impfquote für die über 60
jährigen die wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere bei 97 prozent oder sogar noch
etwas höher liegt und dort haben viele
von denen sogar
fast alle auch drei impfungen das ist
zum beispiel etwas was den markt etwas
sicherer macht den umgang mit dem
möglichen virus infektionswellen die
noch offen zu kommen können und deshalb
bleibt wie wir alle da ist betont haben
und aber auch diejenigen die jetzt nicht
an diesem tisch setzen sondern mit
beraten haben impfen die zentrale
aufgabe die wir haben impfen hilft die
erste impfung hilft schon die zweite
impfung noch mehr die dritte impfung am
allermeisten und das ist das was wir
gerne versuchen zu sagen bevor wir ganz
intensiv werden und wo wir auch nicht
nachlassen dann wenn jetzt der
zwanzigste erreicht es dann geht es
weiter mit dieser aufgabe ich sage
ausdrücklich wir brauchen auch nach dem
zwanzigsten basisschutz darüber besteht
einvernehmen übrigens auch in der
regierung und in der regierungskoalition
also über die das bundeskabinett hinaus
und wir werden sicherstellen dass es
eine gesetzgebung gibt die rechtzeitig
dann ermöglicht dass dieser basis dieser
basis maßnahmen ergriffen werden können
und geregelt werden können und dass sie
den ländern und den wenigen die
verantwortung haben den landkreisen und
den städten auch zur verfügung steht die
dinge die hier genannt sind halte ich
alle für erforderlich und ich bin sicher
dass wir ein gesetzgebungsverfahren
zustande bringen werden dass genau
dieser verantwortung gerecht wird es
wird also ein hoch effektiven
basisschutz geben mit gemeinsamer
beschlussfassung und bundestag und
bundesrat und das ist auch gut so
die frage warum ich gerade vor
gefährlicher weise auch gewisse bitte
ja ich denke dass wir bei aller abwägung
was sie angesprochen haben minderheiten
last mehrheits wünsche wir müssen schon
sehen dass die situation sicher
entwickelt wir haben sinkende
infektionszahlen wir haben keine über
auslastung der kritischen infrastruktur
wir hatten ja immer große sorge dass wir
möglicherweise sogar an einen punkt
kommen an dem wir personalauswahl fall
zwischen 20 und 30 prozent bei der
kritischen infrastruktur haben das ist
aber nicht der fall sondern es pegelt
sich ich kann es für berlin ganz genau
sagen auf etwa 15 prozent ein das es
absolut händelbar und organisierbar und
auch die situation in den schulen in den
kitas ja wir haben krankheitsfälle aber
die sind bei weitem nicht so hoch wie es
zu anderen zeiten war oder befürchtet
wäre und wir sind beim impfen jetzt
mittlerweile auf einem sehr guten weg
was das boostern angeht bei fast 60
prozent gewusst hat der bevölkerung das
ist ein guter schritt und in berlin zum
beispiel sind über 90 prozent der über
60 jährigen bereits geimpft das ist
natürlich in von bundesland zu
bundesland auch etwas unterschiedlich
aber ich kann ihnen sagen es ist ganz
klar dass wir dann auch weiter darum
werben werden und wir wissen alle dass
es schwieriger wird wenn bestimmte
rahmenbedingungen die vielleicht ein
anreiz sein können für das impfen sich
verändern und trotzdem muss man sagen
man darf da auch nicht nachlassen und
gerade das aufsuchende impfen das
dezentrale impfen die ansprache vor ort
das überwinden auch von sprachbarrieren
wir haben das gesehen es gibt durchaus
noch potenzial wenn wir mit
vertrauenspersonen in unterschiedlichen
sprachen vor ort in den kiezen die
menschen ansprechen wenn wir drive-in
angebote organisieren aufsuchende
simpson in gemeindezentren in
verschiedenen stadtteilen die viele
menschen anziehen wo auch über
vertrauenspersonen über multiplikatoren
geworben werden kann haben wir noch
einiges potenzial von menschen die wir
gewinnen können und die beiden
erfolgsrezepte sind ganz einfach
vertrauensbildung durch personen die als
multiplikatoren im kita sind und zum
anderen die ansprache vor ort die
angebote vor ort die auf eine
kontinuität haben darauf müssen wir den
fokus legen und dann ist ganz klar das
in einer situation in der geringeres
infektionsgeschehen geringere gefahr für
kritische infrastruktur geringere
belastung der gesundheitssysteme
einfach auch gelten muss das dann
verhältnismäßig entschieden wird und
dass eben in dem moment wo wir nicht
mehr befürchten dass unsere kritische
infrastruktur in eine sehr kritische
lage kommt dass wir dann auch sagen
müssen wir müssen alle einschränkungen
die wir bisher getroffen haben unter der
maßgabe einerseits der wirksamkeit
andererseits der verhältnismäßigkeit
bewerten und dann auch entsprechend
reagieren und wir haben immer
versprochen werden die lage sich bessert
dann werden schrittweise auch maßnahmen
wieder zurückgenommen und in eine
pandemie reinzukommen ist das eine und
zu verschärfen ist das eine aber zu
lockern und eben verantwortungsvoll
jetzt auf schritte in die normalität
zurück zu gehen jetzt mindestens genauso
schwierig und deshalb ist es ja so
wichtig dass wir eben immer auch noch
die möglichkeit haben sollte doch an der
einen oder anderen stelle ein
ausbruchsgeschehen da sein sollte doch
die notwendigkeit seien sehr schnell zu
reagieren dass wir diese möglichkeit
auch haben und das war uns heute hier
von seiten der länder sehr wichtig und
ich darf ergänzen
auf zum nächsten termin wir haben ja
einen konkreten termin vereinbart und am
17 märz wieder zu treffen im rahmen der
auch des regulären mpk termins wir haben
aber auch vereinbart sollte wider
erwarten eine entwicklung in den vier
wochen sein die es notwendig macht sich
früher zu treffen werden wir das
selbstverständlich machen und dann eben
auch sehr zügig reagieren aber wir haben
jetzt einen konkreten stufenplan
vereinbart für die vier wochen und alle
expertenmeinungen sind so dass wir jetzt
auch die zuversicht haben können das
auch jetzt einfach mal vier wochen lang
auf so umzusetzen wie wir uns heute
diesen plan gemacht haben
verfassungsrechtlichen rahmen unseres
handelns ausgeführt natürlich nicht
wiederholen die pandemie ist nicht
vorbei deswegen das wort achtsamkeit
andere sagen vorsicht wie auch immer und
dazu gehört praktisch dann der basis
darum darum geht es um die schwächsten
auch in dieser phase der öffnung zu
schützen und schule und kita betrieb
aufrecht zu erhalten
das ist der grund für den basisschutz
und etwas zu haben wir haben das mal
instrumentenkasten
genannt
sanitäts kasten abheben dazu gesagt auch
in ordnung aber es geht um eine
rechtsgrundlage für verschiedene
maßnahmen die man eben in anspruch nimmt
wenn man sie braucht nicht einfach so
wenn man an dass er mit verordnungen die
müssen auch einer rechtlichen
überprüfung standhalten laufen alle vier
wochen aus also werden alle vier wochen
eben neu beschlossen das kriegt auch
immer wieder zur abwägung auch im sinne
der verhältnismäßigkeit an aber stand
jetzt gibt es das nach dem 19 nicht ich
frage vor der fischer habe ich eben auch
so verstanden dass er danach gefragt hat
es ist eben so der bundeskanzler hat
sehr richtig gesagt und deswegen wir
brauchen wir jetzt in den nächsten
wochen die arbeit an diesen basisschutz
und ich bin dem bundeskanzler dankbar
dass er die länder dabei
unterstützt wir brauchen das im ergebnis
mindestens einfach als rechtsgrundlage
für den fall der fälle
hätte zwei fragen bitte eine allgemeine
noch mal
herr buschmann hat ja das versprechen
gegeben dass der zwanzigster märz in
freedom day sein soll würden sie herr
bundeskanzler sagen dass die koalition
der fdp ermöglicht dieses versprechen zu
erfüllen und die zweite frage nochmal
zur impfpflicht sie haben vorhin gesagt
dass man diese impfpflicht unbedingt
braucht auch mit blick auf die
wiederkommen dunklen tage dann auf den
herbst auf den winter und so weiter man
musste in ihrer meinung nach die
impfpflicht beschlossen sei also haben
sie dann zeitplan auch im kopf jetzt
noch mal zwei wochen vier wochen was
auch immer und die zweite frage dazu
ihre oder die unter frage dazu die frau
dreyer hat am freitag gesagt sie können
sich vorstellen dass wenn jetzt drei
verschiedene imf anträge in den
bundestag kommen und hinter jedem
vertrag ein paar leute sind aber keine
eigene mehrheit hat dass man sich dann
hinter einem versammelt finden sie dass
eine gute idee
was war die erste frage
haben die hamburg man ermöglicht das
versprechen zu erfüllen
ich
glaube dass die frage der fdp und auch
den bundesminister der justiz nicht
gerecht wird das verfolgt da niemand der
politische verantwortung hat das will
auch keiner so eine party feiern sondern
es geht darum dass wir eine entscheidung
die wir sehr früh getroffen haben und
bei der ich mich sehr darauf verwandt
habe dafür verwandt habe dass wir einen
sehr spät liegenden tempo nehmen jetzt
umsetzen und weiterführen im hinblick
auf das was wir uns dann für die zeit
danach vorgenommen haben und das noch
mal zu sagen die entscheidung aus dem
november
dezember beinhaltete die aussage dass
wir
mit der gesetzgebung sicherstellen dass
zum frühlings ab bis zum frühlingsanfang
all diese maßnahmen die wir jetzt auch
ergriffen haben ergriffen werden können
und da gab es unterschiedliche meinungen
ich habe gesagt das muss so lange wird
und wir haben die maßnahmen ergriffen
und das will ich an dieser stelle noch
mal laut und deutlich sagen und ich
glaube
dass das manchmal schon sinn macht sich
um zu gucken deutschland ist wohl so
ziemlich das erfolgreichste land im
umgang mit der aktuellen pandemie
entwicklung sind nicht super was das
impfen betrifft da sind wir nicht hoch
genug gekommen wir sind sehr gut was den
dass die busse der mvg
auffrischungsimpfung betrifft aber wir
sind mit dem schutz maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen
besser gefahren als andere wir haben
weniger tote weniger leute die infiziert
worden sind wir hatten schlimme
befürchtung einiger unserer
nachbarländer die nicht so viele
einwohner haben wir sind auf infektionen
pro tag von über 500.000 gekommen wenn
es jetzt so läuft wie wir uns das
vorstellen dann sind wir nicht über
250.000 antic gewesen und es geht dann
allmählich runter das darf sich in
diesem land glaube ich jeder auch mal
erzählen die maßnahmen die wir alle
zusammen durchgeführt haben sie bürgern
und bürger die gemeinden die städte die
landkreise die länder der bund die haben
gewirkt sie haben geholfen und sie haben
uns auf einen pfad geführt den andere
nicht verfolgt haben die deshalb mit
mehr infektionen durch diesen winter und
herbst gehen mussten und deshalb ist
deutschland in diesem fall das land das
das richtige gemacht hat mit guten
ergebnissen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und genau darum ist der heutige
tag so wichtig weil wir sagen das waren
zwar beschränkung die andere nicht
hatten
aber sie haben gewirkt aber jetzt wo das
denn sich da wird das will auch da
hingekommen sind müssen wir auch die
öffnungs schritte machen und danach
kommt der basisschutz und der wird
geschlossen wird weiter
regierungsmehrheit und getragen vom
bundesrat das heißt von einem breit
getragenen konsens und wird so umfassend
sein wie er notwendig ist da kann sich
jeder draußen lassen
was
die zukunft betrifft
geht es doch darum dass wir alle
ernst ernst der sache entsprechend
und für die impfpflicht ist man ja nicht
weil man
sich für
ein interview vorbereitet es gibt solche
leute der politik ich zähle ausdrücklich
nicht dazu die allermeisten ich kenne
auch nicht sondern es haben wir alle im
schweren ring gesagt nachdem wir lange
anders gedacht haben weil wir gesehen
haben dass wir mit den jetzt immerhin 75
prozent die zwei impfungen haben
nicht hoch genug liegen und dass wir
auch nicht hoch genug kommen trotz
unserer appelle hier trotz unzähliger
appelle von vielen anderen trotz
unglaublich überzeugen der
wissenschaftler wissenschaftler von
künstlern von leuten den öffentlichkeit
auftreten
mit die zahl derjenigen die sich jetzt
jeden tag neu frisch impfen lassen
gerade nicht zu sondern sie wird weniger
und das alles sind argumente warum wir
uns unterhaken müssen und eine
gemeinsame gesetzgebung zur frage der
impfpflicht zustande bringen müssen
ich persönlich halte das für richtig und
ich habe auch gesagt nicht dass richtig
habe eine der anträge die vorliegt
bringt das auch zum ausdruck dass das ab
dem 18 lebensjahr sein soll und die
stärkere vor dass das zeitlich befristet
ist weil es sich um diese pandemie
gehandelt und ein ganz konkretes virus
mit dem wir uns auseinandersetzen wollen
das legen sich auch fest das ist um drei
impfungen geht und sie sagen das war die
frage das muss gelten ab dem beginn des
monats oktober
also bis dahin werden alle zeit haben
sich die notwendigen impfungen noch zu
beschaffen und deshalb ist mit diesem
klaren sachen ja auch
die frage zu beantworten bis wann muss
das fertig sein ja so rechtzeitig dass
man das bis zum oktober noch schaffen
kann und alles was sich ein zeitplänen
kenne läuft darauf hinaus dass da sogar
noch richtig luft an das für alles was
dann zu tun ist falls man sich
tatsächlich das erst dann über dicht und
vielleicht lassen sie mich die
gelegenheit nutzen das hier auch noch zu
sagen
viele haben ja in ihrem persönlichen
überlegungen
er sagt ach vielleicht lasse ich mich
impfen aber die impfstoffe die bisher da
kennedy sind gefallen mir irgendwie
nicht
wir haben viele wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftler die uns anderes gesagt
haben aber das ist ja trotzdem etwas das
jeder für sich selber überlegen muss und
das sollten wir bei allem eli vergessen
wenn wir über impfung sprechen reden wir
ja über den eigenen körper das geht ja
etwas das man mit sich selber
machen lässt
und da gibt es jetzt demnächst
impfstoffe die sind von uns eingekauft
und sie sind bald geliefert und dann
können sie eingesetzt werden die eine
angebot sind auch für diejenigen die
sich in dieser frage sachlich
eingelassen haben und das wollen wir
auch nicht in den kopf die meisten
bürger haben hier irgendwelche impfungen
gegen grippe gegen tetanus gegen masern
was weiß ich auch immer
es ist ja nicht so dass die dass es sehr
viele gibt die gar keine impfung haben
deshalb hoffe ich dass mit diesem
zusätzlichen impfstoff diejenigen die
dieses argument haben sich nochmal
motivieren
und dann ist mir auch wichtig dass wir
immer wieder sagen
das ist nicht eine sache die wir mit uns
alleine ausmachen sondern wir
entscheiden ja in der uns nicht impfen
lassen
auch über andere über die ganze
gesellschaft mit zum beispiel das was
wir jetzt den ganzen herbst und winter
hatten die sind kontakte schritte die
sind ja deshalb in diesem ausmaß
notwendig gewesen weil die importe noch
ist da hat man ganz vielen andern eine
entscheidung auf genötigt weil ein teil
der bürgerinnen und bürger sich nicht
finden lassen dass nicht in allen in den
krankenhäusern viele jeder so schön
heißt elektiven eingriff also solche die
man auch mal später machen kann jetzt
nicht statt filmen
ist ja nicht nur ein eingriff in den
betrieb der krankenhäuser sondern auch
etwas das folgende hat für bürgerinnen
und bürger die genau diese kann haus
behandlung lange vorher für sich zu
diesem zeitpunkt geplant haben und die
das jetzt erst später machen können und
das müssen wir uns immer sagen darum ist
das wichtig und dann hoffe ich dass
wirklich alle sagen uns ist die sache
wichtig es geht uns um die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger
es geht uns nicht darum
dass wir als parteien am nächsten tag da
oder dort machen und wenn uns das
gelingen würde dann können wir auch
optimistisch sein dass
es dann auch zu einem gesetz kommt dass
das regelt und das muss doch unsere
möglichkeit sein wenn ich jetzt überall
höre auch hier nochmal was ich sehr gut
finde und ausdrücklich begrüße dass die
bereitschaft über die konkrete art und
weise der ausgestaltung der impfpflicht
zu sprechen da ist und dass man das
gemeinsam machen will das ist doch
völlig richtig ich kann sagen genau so
muss es sein das werden wir auch
hinkriegen ich jedenfalls werde alles
dazu beitragen
da habe ich einen blick auf die uhr habe
ich noch zwei fragesteller natürlich
auch gerne beide daran nehmen am anfang
christopher ziedler und danach noch
nadine bada das macht er so weit
ist er gerade zum ausdruck gekommen dass
er den ausdruck freedom day
offensichtlich nicht gebrauchen wollen
in diesem zusammenhang
vielleicht nur kurz die frage warum ich
unangemessen finden was ja gleichzeitig
gesagt habe so ein großer wichtiger tag
auch mit hinblick auf den märz aber vor
allem eine frage zum basisschutz
basisschutz können sie uns noch mal
vielleicht konkretere vorstellungen
geben wie das nach oder nach dem
frühlingsanfang aussehen wird also sind
zb 2g oder 3g regeln wird das sozusagen
er teil des instrumentenkasten sein also
es ist ja schon ausgeführt im beschluss
dass der nachweis geführt werden muss
aber wird 2g und 3g das noch teil
unseres alltags sein oder eben nur im
notfall wenn es im lokal irgendwie zu
ausbruchsgeschehen kommt oder ist das
teilt dessen wie das wir uns maske
abstand und 2g 3g regeln über frühling
und sommer begleiten werden oder ist es
eben nicht dabei das ist mir noch unklar
dankeschön
ich halte von solchen begriff nicht sie
werden dem ernst der lage nicht
angemessen
und deshalb ist das auch
keine formulierung mit der die parteien
der regierung zum beispiel rumlaufen und
was den basisschutz betrifft der ist
natürlich
im wesentlichen an instrumentenkasten so
wie sie das in ihrer frage formuliert
haben denke ich bestimmte dinge die
werden ganz bestimmt auch ganz
unabhängig vom pandemie also vom dem der
von dem datum noch eine zeit lang
genutzt werden müssen wie zum beispiel
die masten oder so aber es gibt auch
bestimmte dinge die muss man einsetzen
der region oder weil sich plötzlich die
lage verschlimmert ohne dass wir jetzt
mit ganz großer neuer gesetzgebung zu
schlagen müssen das sollten wir ja auch
für unsere eigenen möglichkeiten tun und
dazu besteht bereitschaft und das wird
jetzt in der gesetzgebung stattfinden
und der eigens von 1 assist rechtzeitig
hin zu kriegen so dass wir diese
gesetzgebung auch finalisieren können
rechtzeitig zum frühlingsanfang und dann
der instrumentenkasten von allen genutzt
wenn dann wenn sie ein instrument
brauchen
erklärt martin bader
wenn sie gestatten an noch mal
nachfragen bei der impfpflicht dann ist
es ja nicht zum ersten mal so dass sie
sich dazu bekennen auch in einem
beschlusspapier der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mehr ist
immer noch nicht klar geworden trotzdem
nachfragen hier wie sie das jetzt
angehen wollen herr scholz sie haben
sich nochmal jetzt bekannt zu diesem
einen antrag auch von einigen ampel
parlamentariern aber wie wollen sie das
jetzt tatsächlich
anstoßen das mandat gemeinsam zusammen
kommt auch womöglich mit der union und
eine technische frage noch wann soll
denn der erste schritt jetzt sich
vollziehen also das wegfallen der
kontakt beschränkung einige länder sind
da ja schon vorgeprescht da ist glaube
ich kein datum im beschlusspapier
demokratie
und die öffentliche debatte in unserer
gesellschaft funktioniert nur wenn wir
uns wörtlich nehmen
und wenn ich alle wörtlich nehmen wir
mit denen in der politik im deutschen
versammelt bin dann sind alle diejenigen
das ist ja eine breite mehrheit
die irgendwie eine impfpflicht richtig
finden wie zum beispiel die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsident
von spd grünen und cdu
viele abgeordnete von spd fdp grünen und
cdu csu
die dafür sind dass es eine impfpflicht
gibt und sie wollen sich verständigen
dann darf man alle beim wort nehmen dann
macht man und das wird schon gelingt
also das ziehen wir uns meine hoffnung
dass dieser politische prozess
stattfindet und
ich nehme alle wörtlich und auch in
ihrer jährlichen konstruktivität
wir haben ja in den bundesländern
unterschiedliche regelungen in schritt 1
geht es ja vor allen dingen um die frage
der privaten zusammen fünfte für
geimpfte und genießen und natürlich auch
um die regelungen zum einzelhandel da
ist es ja so dass in vielen ländern
schon die entsprechenden beschlüsse
gefasst worden sind in den
landeskabinett in berlin kann ich in
konkret sagen wir gestern den beschluss
zum einzelhandel und zu den fsb zwei
masten gefasst er wird jetzt am freitag
also übermorgen in kraft treten wird
dann gelten soll so eine sehr schnelle
umsetzung auch des mdk beschlusses und
zu den anderen regeln die getroffen sind
wird es natürlich in den jeweiligen
landes kabinetten die befassung geben
und dann auch die zeitnahe
beschlussfassung damit dass dann auch
für den zweiten schritt mit dem vierten
märz da wird natürlich dann im vorfeld
in den landes kabinetten auch die
entsprechende beschlussfassung
nachvollzogen werden und das hängt jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen davon ab wie die
einzelnen zeitabläufe sind aber in den
nächsten zwei wochen werden die
entsprechenden beschlussfassung
änderungen der verordnung darauf
umgesetzt werden
da hat mich herzlich bedanken für ihr
interesse von so gut nach hause und
bedanken die kunsthalle podium und die
bundes und die pressekonferenz
das war die pressekonferenz von
bundeskanzler scholz und den
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidentin
der länder zur aufhebung vieler vieler
corona maßnahmen in drei schritten soll
es wieder ein stück weit richtung
normalität gehen wir wollen die
einzelnen punkte mit nico liegt man vom
zdf hauptstadtstudio jetzt noch mal im
einzelnen durchgehen und ich hoffe auch
dass wir sie gleich sehen können da es
hallo nicole willkommen zurück wie
könnte das war jetzt interessant denn
ich habe so ein bisschen darauf gewartet
dass ein bundeskanzler scholz die
einzelnen punkte
vorträgt und durch ließ so wie wir das
ja von bundeskanzlerin merkel kannten
das hat er jetzt gar nicht gemacht
deshalb gut dass wir unsere kollegin
julia schröter haben die hat die punkte
jetzt für uns nochmal zusammengefasst
in einem ersten schritt soll private
zusammenkünfte für geimpfte und genesene
wieder ohne eine begrenzung der
teilnehmerzahl erlaubt sein anders sieht
es für ungeimpfte aus die bestehenden
einschränkungen für sie gelten weiter
bis zum 19 märz der zugang zum
einzelhandel soll künftig ohne kontrolle
möglich sein dabei muss mindestens eine
medizinische maske getragen werden in
einigen bundesländern gilt auch ffp zwei
masken pflicht ab dem vierten märz soll
in einem zweiten schritt weiter
gelockert werden dann gilt 3g für
gastronomie und übernachtungsgewerbe
rein darf also wer geimpft genesen oder
getestet ist für discos clubs und
großveranstaltungen gilt zweig plus also
geimpft oder genesen + test wer gepustet
ist darf so rein bei großveranstaltungen
den innenräumen gilt 60 prozent der
maximalen auslastung ist erlaubt aber
nicht mehr als 6000 zuschauende im
freien ist mehr drin 75 prozent
auslastung maximal 25.000 zuschauende
ab dem 20 märz sollen dann alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen
wegfallen wenn die lage in den
krankenhäusern das zulässt auch die home
office pflicht soll dann entfallen
ja so weit die einzelnen öffnungs
schritte was dann noch bleiben soll
nicole sind basis schutzmaßnahmen was
genau damit gemeint
basis schutzmaßnahmen da schaue ich mein
leben in das papier das uns ja auch
vorliegt da zählen aus sicht der länder
insbesondere ich zitiere jetzt meine
masten pflichten in den geschlossenen
räumen vom publikums einrichtungen sowie
in bussen und bahnen
das abstandsgebot allgemeine vorgaben
und die möglichkeit in bestimmten
bereichen test erfordernisse vorzusehen
das heißt wir müssen und wir müssen
außerdem weiterhin unseren ins genießen
oder test status vorzeigen können
anschließend steht hier noch diese dass
wir gleich interessant diese
möglichkeiten sind auch für schulen und
kindertageseinrichtungen notwendig genau
das ist gerade schon gesagt
basismaßnahmen
das wird interessant weil das ja in
einem gesetz festgehalten werden muss
und da kam jetzt eben die frage während
der pressekonferenz
auf den kanzler scholz in seiner ampel
koalition das heißt in einer koalition
nicht nur mit den grünen sondern eben
auch mit der fdp hier ein freedom day
versprochen hatte ob er dafür für diese
gesetzlichen änderungen vorgaben wieder
für notwendig sind für diese
basismaßnahmen eine mehrheit in der
ampelkoalition finden würde scholz sagt
man sei sich einig man brauche maß
basismaßnahmen
ich bin mal gespannt ob das tatsächlich
dann auch die basismaßnahmen korte sind
die ich gerade vorgelesen habe oder ob
das für die nächsten querelen
schwierigkeiten innerhalb der ja noch
gar nicht so lange gemeinsam regierenden
ampel sorgen da ist also durchaus noch
zündstoff drin wir haben vorhin über das
im register gesprochen das hat es aber
jetzt nicht von der beschlussvorlage in
die endfassung geschafft was könnten die
gründe seien
ganz genau es hat es nicht in die
endfassung geschafft die
begründung von scholz ist abenteuer es
zieht sich aber wie ein roter faden
durch diese pandemie stolz sagt haben
wir nicht also können was auch nicht
benutzen würde zu lange dauern da sind
wir wieder beim dauerbrenner
beziehungsweise beim dow rohrkrepierer
das trifft nicht nur die ampel das
trifft auch nicht nur die groko die
vorher regiert hat das ist ein
jahrzehntealtes verschleppt es großes
problem hier in deutschland die
digitalisierung
scholz sagt wir machen wir versuchen die
impfpflicht einzuführen wir wollen die
impfpflicht das bekenntnis war ja eben
noch mal sehr klar er persönlich wie die
impfpflicht ohne ein solches register so
und ich habe es ja eben schon gesagt es
wird interessant beim thema schulen und
kindergärten denn das ist ein punkt der
sich in den sogenannten protokoll
erklärungen
wiederfindet die an dieses
beschlusspapier dass uns hier vorliegt
angefügt worden ist das papier besteht
aus elf seiten und allein zwei davon
sind protokoll erklärungen von fünf der
eben an dieser konferenz beteiligten
länder das heißt die einigkeit ist wenn
einige
in einigen punkten nicht so groß und ich
lese vor auf seite 11 protokoll
erklärung der länder hessen und
baden-württemberg
hessen und baden württemberg halten ein
im register für erforderlich um
zukünftig pandemischen lagen wirksam
begegnen zu können das heißt das von der
cdu und das von der cdu regierte hessen
und das grün regierte baden württemberg
bzw die haben ihre mps an der spitze
ihrer regierung aus diesen parteien die
sind unzufrieden damit und möchten noch
einmal betonen dass sie das im register
brauchen und sind unzufrieden damit dass
es eben keine mehrheit gefunden hat in
dieser runde heute genau diese
protokollnotizen werden ja immer gemacht
wenn es länder gibt die mit den
beschlüssen dann nicht ganz zufrieden
sind oder sie eben nicht ausreichend
finden und das wird tatsächlich noch
interessant werden denn es bringt ja
nichts wenn einzelne länder dann ein
impf register haben wollen weil dafür
müsste man sich dann ja schon einig sein
so ist es wir haben ja schon vor der
pressekonferenz darüber gesprochen es
ist ja für uns beide bei weitem auch
nicht die erste mpk wir alle wird im
jahr es gibt den berühmten
flickenteppich anschließend es gibt die
abweichungen der einzelnen länder ich
habe ja gerade schon vorgelesen hessen
und baden württemberg bezieht sich auch
die impfpflicht wir haben hier auch
protokollerklärungen aus bayern da wird
noch mal die einrichtungs bezogene
endlich das bedeutet dann endlich für
menschen die im pflege- und
alteneinrichtungen zum beispiel arbeiten
die wird hier noch mal kritisiert da
hatte markus jordan zwischenzeitlich
signalisiert erwartet diesem gesetz dann
doch nicht folgen dass er mal mit
beschlossen hat auch sachsen kritisiert
die einrichtungs bezogen der impfpflicht
hier
und dann kommt jetzt von der anderen
seite quasi eine protokollerklärung von
schleswig holstein da ist die lage
vergleichsweise gut da ist die impfquote
liegt über dem bundesdurchschnitt die
lage in den krankenhäusern ist entspannt
und
deswegen schreibt schließlich holstein
gibt hier noch mal zu protokoll es
strebt auch eine wie es hier heißt
moderate anpassung der kontakt
beschränkungen für zusammenkünfte an an
denen auch ungeimpfte teilnehmen wir
haben das ja eben gehört diese drei
schritte
in denen jetzt erstmal oder nach denen
jetzt erstmal überlagert werden soll
der erste schritt bedeutet ja dass die
kontakt beschränkungen aufgehoben werden
allerdings für geimpfte und für genießen
und wie gesagt sie sich holstein wieder
weiter gehen und das auch für ungeimpfte
im zweifel zulassen das heißt also es
scheren schon wieder erste länder aus
dass dann schon in dem beschlusspapier
bevor die pressekonferenz überhaupt
angefangen hat wir wollten ja vorhin
über das thema genießen den status
sprechen und dann hat er die presse
konnte einst angefangen lass uns das
noch mal kurz machen in dem beschluss
steht jetzt tatsächlich dass das robert
koch institut und das paul-ehrlich-
institut jetzt doch nicht mehr dafür
zuständig sein sollen und unser kollege
andreas kienast hat ja eben in der
pressekonferenz danach gefragt ob das
eben die entmachtung von rk ii chef
wieder ist und die antwort von kanzler
scholz würde ich jetzt mal vorsichtig
als nun eindeutig bezeichnen wie schätzt
du das 1
naja natürlich ist das entmachtung also
vor allem wenn man sich auch noch
anguckt dann ist diese änderung gab hin
zum rüber koch institut das ist nämlich
gerade mal vier wochen her da ist die
beschlossen worden und dann nagel mich
nicht fest vielleicht auch fünf und dann
gab es ja ein sehr großes chaos weil
wirklich über nacht plötzlich der
genesenen status die dauer des genesenen
status
verkürzt wurde halbiert wurde und sehr
viele menschen eiskalt überrascht
scholz hat lothar wieler den leiter hat
den präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts danach in schutz
genommen das musste er auch weil
insbesondere die fdp sich auf wieder ein
geschossen hatte
und auch karl lauterbach
der bundesgesundheitsminister wie scholz
spd politiker hat sich
schützend vor kinder gestellt hat aber
auch gleichzeitig jetzt in einem
interview gesagt er möchte nicht
politisch dafür verantwortlich gemacht
werden was andere beschließen und de
facto ist das eine entmachtung wie lass
mit gleichzeitig erstmal an ihm
festhalten
lass uns noch mal auf punkt 10 schauen
der ist gar nicht angesprochen worden
aber ich denke dass er gerade für viele
familien wichtig sein könnte die
einstufung der hochrisiko gebiete soll
überarbeitet werden und damit erinnert
sich natürlich auch einiges für diese
rückreise quarantine
genau ich lese dass man einmal vor das
haben ja wahrscheinlich nicht alle zu
hause jetzt diese beschlussvorlage um
den durch micon weltweit gestiegenen
inzidenz in rechnung zu tragen wird der
bund die einstufung der hochrisiko
gebiete anpassen damit soll vor allem
auch das reisen für familien erleichtert
werden da kinder unter zwölf jahren oft
nicht geimpft sind und sie daher antenne
nicht entgehen können dies soll bei der
anstehenden überprüfung der
einschlägigen regelungen berücksichtigt
werden das bedeutet man will das locker
man will familien
ermöglichen auch dann zu reisen und auch
zurück zu reisen
es kommt ja auch immer auf die
perspektive an nach deutschland ohne
dass die kinder anschließend fünf tage
in quarantäne müssen oder auch länger je
nachdem
unter 12 jährige stehe ich hier ja auch
gerade sind ja oft nicht geimpft es gibt
ja keine empfehlung keine ausdrückliche
empfehlung der stiko dazu außer für vor
erkrankte kinder und
da man jetzt sagt omikron ist ja nicht
so gefährlich wie delta können wir das
ein bisschen lockerer hand haben so dass
familien eben zwölfjährige kinder
zwischen sechs und zwölf gehen in die
schulen die können dann teilweise reifen
gar nicht antreten weil die kinder dann
nach den ferien noch zu hause bleiben
müssten und dem schulunterricht
fernbleiben das heißt es ja was soll
einfacher werden wieder auch in
hochrisiko gebiete die sie jetzt sind zu
reisen ich weiß nicht ob die dann anders
genannt werden oder ob einfach die
regelung regelung für hochrisiko gebiete
angepasst werden und einen punkt noch
den ich gerne von der politisch
eingeschätzt haben gehabt hätte es ist
ja manchmal interessant wie solche
runden politisch ist immer verwendet
werden wir hören bayerns
ministerpräsident söder der sagt mit
blick auf die beschlüsse bayern hat den
trend gesetzt unser beschlossene
fahrplan wird jetzt in ganz deutschland
angewendet kann er das so sagen
na ja wissen markus söder kann sehr viel
sagen und markus söder würde einen
teufel tun selbst wenn es so wäre sich
vor kameras zu stellen und zu sagen ich
habe leider verloren unsere funktioniert
politik ja nicht
naja also auch bayern ist ja hier mit
einer protokollerklärung vertreten drei
jahren versucht jetzt noch mal die
kritik klar zu machen an an der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
nochmal markus söder ist ja nicht erst
seit dieser mdk oder der davor
ministerpräsident von der hat auch
damals damals schon an der er
teilgenommen an der die einrichtungs
bezogen endlich beschlossen wurde
bayern gibt aber auch hier zu protokoll
dass kinder und jugendliche in schulen
und kitas
besser geschützt werden müssen
beziehungsweise dass man die im blick
behalten muss wenn die bisherigen
schutzmaßnahmen wegfallen oder
abgeschwächt werden dazu muss man wissen
das ist eigentlich ländersache das ist
frage das ist eine frage die in erster
gehen wir von der
kultusministerkonferenz
entschieden wird beziehungsweise erst
mal besprochen wird und die instanzen
unter schülerinnen und schüler in
schülern und bayern sind überall hoch in
bayern sind sie auch sehr sehr hoch also
das heißt markus söder macht mit solchen
aussagen natürlich auch immer den
versuch sich gut darzustellen darin ist
da ein meister
bayern hatte stets sehr hohe instanzen
wenn man markus söder teilweise hörte
konnte man das in zweifel ziehen aber
zahlen liegen ja nur mal nicht also ich
glaube dass er tatsächlich sich in
vielen punkten hier durchgesetzt hat bzw
dass er zu
zu einer zu mehrheiten gehört hatte
brauchte aber natürlich guckt auch
markus söder verein markus söder der tut
das sehr genau auf umfragewerte die sind
gerade nicht gut und klappern gehört
einfach zum handwerk vielen dank nicole
diekmann für deine politische
einschätzung einen schönen nachmittag
oder abend noch keys
danke sehr gerne und wir wollen das
ganze jetzt auch noch immunologisch
einschätzen lassen und wenn man auf
viele fragen von userinnen und usern und
deshalb begrüße ich jetzt frau
professorin christine falk von der
deutschen gesellschaft für immunologie
schönen guten tag
frank können sie mich hören
ja ich glaube
sie kann ich ja schon das war die
schrecksekunde
vorfalls wir haben die
pressekonferenz eben auch gesehen wie
würden sie jetzt die beschlüsse aus
ihrer professionellen sicht bewerten
und jetzt erstmals zum vierten märz dann
der zwanzigste märz und dann danach mit
bitte klaren maßgabe oder es wird das
alles mit den bewertungen wie sich die
instanzen bewegen auch die krankenhaus
gelegen und die hospitalisierung und die
intensivstationen und
die sinkenden zahlen die wir jetzt
gerade haben glaube ich an dieser
plan ist der ja auch gut von
der politischen einzelwerten weiter
entspannen wird so entwickelt dass man
den menschen auch wirklich sagt es hat
funktioniert jetzt wirklich disziplin zu
behalten die maßnahmen jetzt noch länger
zu behalten weil sie erfolgreich an wir
haben tatsächlich nicht diese hohen
zahlen wir haben eine infrastruktur die
in bedrängnis gekommen ist und dass man
auf dieser soliden basis jetzt
tatsächlich die schritte geht
mein kollege in der region sagt mir
gerade sehr muss auch gehört dass die
tonqualität einfach nicht gut ist und
wir mal kurz einen beitragen sie
eigentlich und versieht sie leiten die
professorin falk nochmal aufzubauen in
der hoffnung dass es besser wird
ja jetzt sollte ein beitrag kommen an
dieser stelle ich hoffe man den ab
stephan in einem ersten schritt sollen
private zusammenkünfte für geimpfte und
genesene wieder ohne eine begrenzung der
teilnehmerzahl erlaubt sein anders sieht
es für ungeimpfte aus die bestehenden
einschränkungen für sie gelten weiter
bis zum 19 märz der zugang zum
einzelhandel soll künftig ohne kontrolle
möglich sein dabei muss mindestens eine
medizinische maske getragen werden in
einigen bundesländern gilt auch ffp zwei
masken pflicht ab dem 4 märz soll in
einem zweiten schritt weiter gelockert
werden dann gilt 3g für gastronomie und
übernachtungsgewerbe rein darf also wer
geimpft genesen oder getestet ist für
discos clubs und großveranstaltungen
gilt zweig plus also geimpft oder
genesen + test wer gepustet ist darf so
rein bei großveranstaltungen in
innenräumen gilt 60 prozent der
maximalen auslastung ist erlaubt aber
nicht mehr als 6000 zuschauende im
freien ist mehr drin 75 prozent
auslastung maximal 25.000 zuschauende
ab dem 20 märz sollen dann alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen
wegfallen wenn die lage in den
krankenhäusern das zulässt auch die home
office pflicht soll dann entfallen
frau professorin feiert wir starten
einen neuen versuch schön dass sie bei
uns sind ich hatte sie ja eben gefragt
wie sie die beschlüsse bewerten und
leider waren sie nicht so wirklich gut
zu verstehen vielleicht konzerten immer
kurz für uns zusammen fassen dann hoffe
ich dass jetzt der ton besser rüberkommt
hier war eigentlich alles ganz gut ich
hoffe sie wollen mich jetzt besser
der stufenplan ist sehr gut weil er
tatsächlich aufbaut auf dem was sie
erreicht haben dadurch dass wir in den
letzten wochen die disziplin gehalten
haben die zahlen nicht so hoch gegangen
sind die meisten bundesländern nicht
alle gehen mit den infektionszahlen
runter krankenhaus belegung intensiv
bewegung ist eine stabile basis und
darauf jetzt ein stufenplan aufzubauen
wo die menschen wissen dass wir den
vierten märz haben den zwanzigsten märz
und danach diese basis maßnahme ist
glaube ich ein sehr guter schritt vor
allem den menschen die geimpft und
genesen sind mehr freiheiten als erstes
zu geben das glaube ich auch noch mal
ein dankeschön an die menschen die
wirklich mitgemacht haben und diese
möglichkeit auch mit erarbeitet haben
das jetzt wirklich auf schritte gehen
könnt ihn nachvollziehbar sind wir
können nur hoffen dass die bundesländer
das möglichst einheitlich umsetzen damit
es einfach leichter wird mit diesen
maßnahmen umzugehen also ich muss sagen
ich finde diesen plan sehr gut weil er
auf einer soliden basis aufbaut und sehr
nachvollziehbare schritte beinhaltet
lassen sie uns ein paar fragen von
userinnen und usern klären wir haben
eine frage auf youtube wie so bleibt die
masten pflicht eben als basis
schutzmaßnahmen das haben wir gelernt
wenn alle anderen maßnahmen abgeschafft
werden
es ist ja so wir sehen ja dass diese
infektionszahlen haben und wir wollen
natürlich nicht dass das komplett quasi
ungehindert das virus das wir ja schon
zirkulieren haben dass das sich noch
weiter ausbreiten kann und bei diesem
virus ist es ja so bei der omicron
variante die sich sehr im
nasen-rachen-raum auch wirklich vermehrt
ist die maske tatsächlich ein wirksamer
schutz das bedeutet mit einer maske kann
man selbst wenn man sich angesteckt hat
aber es noch nicht weiß ja theoretisch
andere menschen anstecken aber mit der
maske kann man das verhindern deswegen
ist hier eine sehr gute und ja auch sehr
niedrigschwellige maßnahme um zu
verhindern dass wenn man jetzt alles
aufgeben würde sich das virus doch
nochmal ausbreiten würde und das ist ja
gerade das was wir so prima verhindert
haben in den wochen jetzt die und hinter
uns liegen daher ist die maske genau das
richtige mittel und das genau die
richtige maßnahme mit der wir das jetzt
auch kontrolliert in die öffnung
begleiten können wir lesen in unserer
community auf youtube dass das durchaus
ein umstrittenes thema ist und eben auch
verbunden mit der frage wann können die
masten dann auch mal wegfallen
es ist ja so dass die massen ja nicht
permanent getragen werden müssen sondern
in den innenräumen ist es einfach so
dass das virus sich dann mit der
atemluft in der luft halten kann und
omikron scheint sich ziemlich gut in der
luft halten zu können deswegen sind
innenräume öffentlicher
personennahverkehr und ähnliche dinge wo
menschen in innenräumen zusammenkommen
immer ein thema solange wir auch so hohe
infektionszahlen haben mit menschen die
im theoretisch das virus weiter geben
können irgendwo müssen sich die vielen
menschen ja anstecken es ist ja schon so
und deshalb sind masken wie ich finde
sind ja auch immer mit masken am
arbeitsplatz unterwegs wenn man maske
auch es gab je nachdem wie viele leute
in einem raum ist man eigentlich sehr
gut beraten weil wir eben nicht einfach
sagen können wir machen einen schritt
und alles auf sondern diese schrittweise
öffnung mit beibehaltung der masken in
inneren macht total sinn um einfach zu
verhindern dass sich mehr menschen
anstecken als notwendig wir haben ja in
der bund länder runde gelernt dass diese
runde eben hinter der impfpflicht steht
und das sei eine frage von sascha der
wissen möchte wenn wir dann besser
gefahren sind als andere gerade jetzt in
dieser welle wozu brauchen wir dann die
impfpflicht
wir sind ja besser gefahren ist eine
sehr gute frage weil wir ja maßnahmen
hatten und das ist ja genau der punkt es
gab ja schon vor weihnachten die klare
erklärung wir müssen mit dieser armee
konnte die sehr ansteckend ist maßnahmen
beibehalten damit bei uns eben nicht
geht dieser extrem hohe anstieg der in
manchen ländern ja wirklich aussah wie
so eine wand damit es bei uns nicht
passiert also mit den maßnahmen sind wir
da sehr gut durch die letzten wochen
gekommen wenn wir die maßnahmen jetzt
wegnehmen wenn es tatsächlich die frage
wie können wir verhindern dass sich das
virus trotzdem so ausbreitet gerade weil
wir diese immunität lücke haben also
doch über zehn prozent der über 60
jährigen die nicht geimpft sind und fast
20 prozent der 18 bis 59 jährigen die
nicht geimpft sind das sind menschen die
einfach ein hohes risiko haben sich
anzustecken weil sie gar keinen
immunschutz haben wenn wir das mit in
diese frage wie gehen wir mit der
gesellschaftlichen verbreitung des virus
um und wollen das begrenzen dann ist es
tatsächlich so dass die massnahmen uns
sehr gut geholfen haben das sehr moderat
zu halten aber das über 200.000 ist ja
nicht moderat ist sind ja viele menschen
die sich anstecken also um zu verhindern
dass unter den vielen die sich anstecken
leute sind die dann schweren verlauf
haben braucht man tatsächlich diese
maßnahme wenn wir die wegnehmen dann ist
tatsächlich wirklich die info an die
leute die noch nicht die fünfzehnte
jetzt wirklich den ernst der lage zu
erkennen weil die impfung der beste
schutz ist davor schwer zu erkranken und
deswegen ist es wirklich so wir brauchen
diese mitteilung dass unser ziel ist vor
allem für den nächsten herbst winter und
es ziehen muss wirklich sein eine
möglichst hohe ins team quote zu
bekommen gerade in der 60 gruppe und
wenn wir das so zu sagen ihr besser wir
das kommunizieren desto weniger
notwendig ist dass gesetzliche maßnahmen
dafür zu ergreifen also es ist wirklich
das ziel das wir vor augen haben sollten
weil wir wollen ja gerade keine
maßnahmen haben und trotzdem eine hohe
impfrate die uns dann für den herbst
winter einfach sehr viel besser
aufstellt deswegen ist es schon wichtig
das zu kommunizieren wie wichtig das
impfen jetzt ist und bleibt wir bleiben
aber unserem klientel und bleiben auch
beim impfen denn es gibt nach wie vor
viele fragen dazu julia sagt zum
beispiel was ich nicht verstehe wieso
müssen genesene sich impfen lassen dass
es doch der natürlichste schutz den man
nur haben kann
das ist nicht ganz so bei jedes virus
hat natürlich immer die idee die
immunantwort zu unterlaufen sonst könnte
es nicht gut infizieren also habe ich
immer zwei weg miteinander
konkurrierende wettstreiten die kräfte
das eine ist das virus das will viel
infizieren und das andere ist das
immunsystem für das versucht das zu
verhindern
und deswegen ist nie so ganz klar wer
wirklich gewinnt daher ist die immunität
die man sich mit einer infektion
einhandelt sozusagen nicht zwingend so
gut und nachhaltig weil das virus ja
versucht dagegen zu arbeiten das
versuchen wir immer das brauchen sie
sonst könnten sie ja gar nicht gut
infizieren also ist die immunität nach
einer infektion kürzer und sie bildet
meistens kein gutes immunologisches
gedächtnis das heißt gerade bei omikron
sieht man das jetzt schon wer sich jetzt
zum ersten mal mit omikron ansteckt wird
nicht im herbst geschützt sein weil
dieser immunität nach omikron
kurzlebiger ist weil man sich dann
wieder anstecken kann und kein gutes
immunologisches gedächtnis bildet wenn
man aber erst sich angesteckt hat dann
die stiko empfohlen empfehlung annimmt
und sich dann nach einem halben jahr
impfen lässt dann entwickelt sich dieses
immunologische gedächtnis weil die
impfung ist quasi eine einbahnstraße in
richtung sehr guter impfschutz da ist
keiner der dagegen arbeitet und deswegen
ist die kombination dann aus infektion
plus in form idealerweise dann zweimal
impfen sozusagen genau der richtige weg
um auch einen langfristigen immunschutz
zu erreichen denn wir alle sind der
ansicht dass wir mit diesen drei
impfungen für leute die ein gesundes
immunsystem haben sehr gut aufgestellt
sind und eine immunologische gedächtnis
bildung erreichen mit der wir auch
längerfristig geschützt sind auch in
richtung herbst findet vielleicht noch
eine frage zum thema impfen manfred
möchte auf facebook wissen wann kommt
der impfstoff für unter fünfjährige und
wie gut ist
das ist genau das was uns gerade
beschäftigt weil bei den kindern unter
fünf jahren wurde ja auch eine sehr viel
geringere dosis verwendet von pfizer und
biotech und da ist es tatsächlich jetzt
so dass man gesehen hat dass zwar die
nebenwirkungen nicht das problem sind
zum glück denn das ist ja das
allerwichtigste dass man auch ein sehr
gutes monitoren der möglichen
nebenwirkungen macht gerade bei kindern
aber dass die impf wirkung nicht so gut
war das kann sein dass es etwas mit der
konzentration zu tun hat des impfstoffes
dadurch dass das nicht so klar ist muss
wirklich noch mal hinterfragt werden wie
die wirksamkeit des schutzes ist er bei
den unter fünfjährigen vermittelt wird
und daran sieht man auch wie wirklich
verantwortungsvoll mit dieser frage
umgegangen wird wie gut und wie sicher
aber auch wie wirksam ist der impfstoff
und da muss man glaube ich noch mal
abwarten bis die studien größere
probanden zahlen eingeschlossen haben
und bis man das besser bewerten kann
deswegen können wollte könnte ich im
moment nicht sagen wann der kommt aber
es ist auf jeden fall so dass das noch
mal sehr genau angeguckt werden muss und
die studien wirklich nochmal
möglicherweise um die probanden zahl
erhöht werden muss und besser heraus zu
finden warum das nicht so gut ist wie
man das bei den 85 jährigen jahr sehr
gut gesehen hat wo ja die wirksamkeit
sehr hoch ist sogar höher als bei
erwachsenen ändert hat wenn jetzt
gelockert wird kann man ja eigentlich
davon ausgehen dass die zahlen erst mal
wieder steigen oder kommt uns dann die
wärmere jahreszeit entgegen und leicht
das aus wie wird das kommen das klingt
was du als auch vom wetter abhängig wäre
und ein bisschen ist es ja auch so also
das ist ändert hat so wenn wir jetzt
mehr möglich machen gott sei dank in
stufen was ich sehr gut finde dann haben
wir einmal den saisonalen effekt der uns
hilft aber dazu brauchen wir den auch es
ist noch nicht frühling also wir sind da
schon noch ein bisschen weg in den
nächsten vier wochen das ist der eine
aspekt das wird uns auf jeden fall
helfen aber gerade der februar märz ist
vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu früh ab
april hat es sonst immer einen guten
effekt gehabt und das zweite ist
natürlich wenn man jetzt mehr menschen
zusammenkünfte ermöglicht gerade bei den
großveranstaltungen haben wir auch
gesehen im außenbereich und im
innenbereich mit der auslastung zwar
unter zum teil je nach dem zweig
regelungen aber trotzdem ist es
natürlich denkbar dass die zahlen wieder
steigen das wichtige ist aber und das
mussten wir den letzten wochen wirklich
lernen in den letzten sechs acht wochen
wenn die menschen geimpft sind um selbst
wenn sie sich dann an stecken haben sie
in der regel keinen schweren verlauf
weil die impfung davor schützt das soll
sie ja auch und das tut sie das mussten
wir bei echten lernen dass es auch
wirklich trägt dass die impfung das tut
was sie soll nämlich wirklich schützen
dass man richtig schwer krank wird das
heißt aber nicht dass die leute gar
nicht krank werden ich glaube jeder von
uns kennt kolleginnen kollegen aus dem
freundeskreis oder in der familie sie
drei mal geimpft waren sich angesteckt
haben und schon eine woche krank waren
also auch omikron ist quasi kein
schnupfen das ist schon echtes virus
aber wenn man eben drama geimpft ist
dann hat man leichte symptome und keine
schwere erkrankung wenn uns das weiter
trägt dann sind auch die höheren zahlen
nicht das thema deswegen haben wir zu im
expertenrat auch darauf hingewiesen dass
wir weiterhin amra auf dem radar haben
müssen wie viele leute stecken sich an
wie viele hospitalisierung haben wir und
wie viel intensiv belegung damit man
sieht dass diese immunisierung auch
trägt denn wenn diese infektion dann
doch wieder die menschen die noch nicht
geimpft und erreicht dann kann es eben
schon sein dass die zahlen für
hospitalisierung dann nochmal ansteigen
das müssen wir alles sehr genau mit
koppeln und dieses monitoring wird uns
sehr helfen wie gut sozusagen die
impfung trägt und wie wir das als
gesellschaft in den nächsten wochen
jetzt hinkriegen schauen wir gerade
nochmal auf die über 60-jährigen der
expertenrat dem sie auch angehören der
weist darauf hin dass die zahl bei den
über 60-jährigen gerade wieder steigt am
wozu kann das führen könnte dass im
schlimmsten fall dazu führen dass
lockerungsmaßnahmen dann auch wieder
zurückgenommen werden müssten
diese frage hängt natürlich damit
zusammen wie viele der menschen dass es
ein bisschen über zehn prozent der über
60 jährigen sind nicht geimpft und nicht
gelesen da wir das aber nicht wissen
können wir sozusagen nur jeden tag auf
das imwf de sport gucken und sehen dass
es immer noch so viele menschen ohne
impfung sind wir wären echten stück
weiter wenn wir wüssten wie viele davon
gelesen sind aber genau diese daten
verknüpfung haben wir nicht deswegen ist
es so dass man sagt prävention bedeutet
die menschen zu schützen die ein höheres
risiko haben einen schweren verlauf zu
haben das ist nun mal ab 60 wenn man gar
keinen immunschutz hat es kann sein dass
sich darunter auch eine gruppe befindet
die sich schon mal angesteckt hat und
einen gewissen immunschutz hat dann ist
das besser so zu sagen weil weniger
menschen und hohes risiko haben aber
genau das wissen wir nicht und das ist
der punkt wo wir wirklich jetzt auch
klar gesagt haben wir brauchen auch eine
sehr gute erfassung der menschen die
infiziert sind und dann doch ein
krankenhausaufenthalt notwendig wird
oder sogar eine intensivmedizinische
behandlung und weil wir dieses diese
zahl oder diese risikogruppen nicht
besser beziffern können müssen wir es
tatsächlich sehr gut verfolgen und zwar
so dass wir nicht immer den rückspiegel
gucken sozusagen sondern dass wir mit
den zahlen sehr schnell sehen wenn das
wieder ansteigt und dann ist es ja klar
es wurde mehrfach gesagt die indikatoren
brauchen wir weiter und wir müssen
rechtzeitig handeln können bevor die
intensivstationen unter druck geraten
dass es genau das was wir jetzt mit
einem schnelleren monitoren gerne
erreichen möchten ich denke da sind wir
alle auf einem sehr guten weg da haben
voll an krankenhäuser und auch alle die
im medizinsystem arbeiten richtig gute
arbeit geleistet den letzten wochen
thema mutationen wenn man den virus
jetzt wieder mehr spielraum lässt wie
ist da das risiko dass eben neue
varianten auftreten kann zur scholz hat
vorhin ja in der pressekonferenz auch
gesagt man muss dann aufpassen dass
nicht das nächste virus um die ecke
kommt
bis jetzt haben wir ja schon immer
gesehen dass das nächste virus um die
ecke kam aus ländern in denen sehr viel
virus zirkuliert ist und in denen der
immunschutz relativ gering war omikron
bei südafrika oder botswana auf jeden
fall eben süden afrikas mann hatte
seinen ursprung es ist tatsächlich so je
mehr menschen sich infizieren desto mehr
hat ein virus die möglichkeit
auszuprobieren ob es sich nicht noch
verbessern kann weil es eben so viele
menschen mit bios replikation also
virusvermehrung im nasen rachen raum
gibt es ist aber schon so dass die
beobachtet haben dass in den ländern in
denen noch deutliche höhere virus zahlen
zu beobachten sind gerade auch afrikaner
sehr interessant ist das sind nämlich
viele menschen die zb auch hiv-positiv
sind die können sehr viel schlechter mit
dieser virusinfektion umgehen da kann
sich so ein virus über wochen in einem
körper erhalten und durchaus verändern
das heißt es ist nicht so sehr zu
erwarten ganz vorsichtig mal in die
glaskugel geguckt dass sich das bei uns
entwickelt eine neue variante sondern
eher in ländern in denen sehr viel
weniger impfschutz da ist und
gleichzeitig eine höhere gruppe von
menschen die möglicherweise länger mit
dieser infektion zu kämpfen haben daher
ist es wichtig darauf hinzuweisen es
geht nicht nur um die frage wie
deutschland geimpft ist sondern wie die
ganze welt geimpft ist unter sehen will
ja dass es enorme unterschiede gibt
deswegen ist der hinweis durchaus
berechtigt aber gilt eigentlich nicht so
sehr für deutschland sondern wirklich
auch für andere länder wo die situation
noch mal eine ganz andere ist unsere
hauptstadt korrespondent in nicole
diekmann die wir hier immer auch im
stream hat vorhin erzählt dass es ein
internes papier des
robert-koch-institutes gibt wo man ganz
fest mit einer neuen welle im herbst
winter rechnet was hilft was können wir
jetzt alle tun damit wir nicht im herbst
winter wieder in diesem schlamassel
reinkommen
das ist genau die diskussion die wir
haben die menschen die jetzt noch nicht
geimpft sind selbst wenn die sich
anstecken ist es bei omikron so dass wir
davon ausgehen können und das zeigen die
ersten daten aus anderen ländern wo
micon schon länger unterwegs ist dass
die leute dann nicht mehr immun sind
wenn wir in den nächsten herbst winter
kommen das ist genau der punkt wo wir
argumentieren die frage von vorhin total
richtig warum macht es sinn sich nach
einer infektion impfen zu lassen damit
man diesen impfpuder diese immunität
verfestigt und gedächtnisbildung drauf
setzt das heißt die antikörper werden
besser und mehr und die t zellen das
gedächtnis werden robuster und halten
länger
wenn wir das nicht schaffen die menschen
die jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind sich
zu überzeugen sich impfen zu lassen
von mir aus nach einer infektion damit
einfach dieser immunschutz in unserer
gesellschaft höher wird als er jetzt ist
dann haben wir das gleiche risiko im
herbst wieder wir wissen nämlich nicht
ob es noch andere varianten geben kann
das weiß keiner es ist eben nicht
auszuschließen und dann stehen wir
möglicherweise vor einer neuen virus
welle die ich gar nicht heraufbeschwören
will aber man muss zumindest damit
rechnen
und je mehr menschen geimpft sind desto
besser können wir die abwettern weil wir
sehen dass die impfstoffe die wir jetzt
haben eine sehr breite abdeckung haben
weil omikron ja nur diese erste
immunität im nasen-rachen-raum so ein
bisschen überwinden kann aber danach
hält die impfung ja sehr gut das virus
in schach das trägt weiter also es ist
die einfache aussage je mehr menschen
sich tatsächlich dann impfen lassen
desto besser sind hier geschützt vor was
auch immer kommen mag und dann trägt das
sehr viel besser und deswegen sollte man
tatsächlich klug sein und rechtzeitig
erkennen wenn es neue variante nirgendwo
auf der welt gibt und sich dann
vorzubereiten damit man es nicht wieder
verpasst das haben wir schon ein paar
mal gehabt wo wir gesagt haben nein die
zahlen steigen an das wird noch mal eine
welle geben und dann man einfach zu
träge im handeln ist auf den
verschiedenen ebenen und dann doch noch
mal ne welle entgleisen lässt das wollen
wir ja alle nicht also können wir uns
jetzt im sommer und im frühherbst
sozusagen sehr gut darauf vorbereiten
wenn wir mehr menschen davon überzeugen
sich impfen zu lassen weil das wirklich
der weg ist sich kollektiv besser zu
schützen
jetzt wollen wir erst mal guten mutes
richtung frühling sommer gehen
idealerweise ohne eben den herbst winter
aus dem blick zu verlieren vielen dank
für ihre erklärungen frau professorin
christine feil
ich danke ihnen und dafür dass der ton
im zweiten teil besser war wunderbar
werden sie astrein gehört
ja und auch ihnen am vielen dank für
ihre fragen und ihre statements und zum
schluss möchte ich noch eins von thomas
auf facebook vorlesen er schreibt am 20
märz soll alles aufgehoben werden naja
alles ist es ja nicht aber vieles ich
kann es wirklich nicht glauben
andererseits wäre es das schönste
geschenk zum frühlingsanfang machen sie
es gut